did you know though that like uh
we're talking sneakers i know that the
converse are bad
you have hardened feet on the bottom
yeah i have
it's i'm not gonna lie to you i have
such dainty
sauce the under my dog's hair if i wear
if i go barefoot in my house my dog's
hair sticks in my feet
wow like i have such soft have you ever
had have you had real foot problems or
like bunions
or no you need to get out into nature
more barely
i think maybe because my weight because
i love to run long distance yeah so i
got plantar fasciitis like the worst
you've
like i could barely get out of bed
really now i got insoles and then i have
no
kids because i wear so many different
shoes all the time said it made it worse
but then i have insoles i just put the
insoles in the
shoe and i have no problems yeah that
helps yeah i never had a problem i used
to run
around a 100 kilometer race for the navy
up and down mountains no dramas didn't
even train for it god bless you yeah
just
i don't know it's lucky do you have do
you
there's more pressure or less pressure
or equal pressure
put on that foot on most of my
pressure's on the good leg
more yeah yeah it does most of the work
like i have to do a lot of
sort of rolling on balls and stuff like
that to loosen up my hips
those physio balls and even a baseball
you get that into your glutes and your
hips
incredible yeah it hurts like a mother
but it's so good for loosening up all
your lower back your hips your legs all
that stuff
yeah you're in great shape you stay in
great shape yeah yeah i'm trying
vegan are you vegan yeah four years yeah
[ __ ] yeah i love it what made you go
vegan oh i was working with
damian mander who runs the international
anti-poaching foundation uh his movie
his documentary comes out today actually
uh akashinga
it's uh it's on i believe nat geo okay
i'm not supposed to promote them because
i'm on discovery channels
but it's a it's a story about his team
all female run anti-poaching unit from
the rangers to the managers to everyone
it's all female
that got laughed out by the guys in the
beginning and now
everyone gives them the respect that
they deserve it's called akashinga which
means the brave ones
and they're they're out of they're
trying to save animals where in zimbabwe
can i ask you something about the
anti-poachers because i know their
poachers obviously
just by definition they're not following
any laws did they have to follow any
laws when they hunt the
i mean hunting poachers isn't the right
term but you know what i mean
i i believe when when damien first went
out there
uh the law was i think it was mugabe
said that poachers could be shot on so
that's what i had heard you're allowed
to hunt the poacher but he
but him being a humongous white
australian guy he didn't want to get
anyone offside so
he was trying to arrest them and that's
what he continued to do so i went out
there and worked with him for a couple
of weeks shooting a documentary
embedded with the rangers like went
through unarmed combat training
they gave me a five minute lesson on how
to handle a snake and then gave me a
deadly black mamba
so like i immersed myself right into it
wait wait what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean what do you mean
they gave you what do you mean they gave
it to you
like they put a handed black mamba on
the ground
he gave me a like the scooping pole yeah
and so
i i didn't i needed my good hand to grab
the tail of the snake and my job was to
get it from the ground catch it and put
it into the tub
and so i needed this hand for catching
the tail and i need this hand for
holding the the snake pole
and so i put it in my hand but the
problem is when i lift up something
heavy
the muscle can activate sometimes opens
the hand and drops it and so i
i could turn it off i can press that
button turn the hand off so it won't
open
so i did that had the pole scooped up
the snake grabbed the tail
but the weight of the pole and the snake
together were too heavy
my wrist rotated dropped the pole and
the snake to the ground
the snake started coming back up the
pole towards my face
so i can't everyone's the camera guys
have stopped filming everyone's
screaming at me to drop the snake they
don't know i can't because i've turned
the hand off and so i've got the tail
here
and i'm doing this crazy snake dance
trying to create distance between
its head its tail and my body just
bouncing all everyone
screaming at me finally got it under
control put it in the bucket and
that was it done with snakes for me
like there's something in you that
isn't in me like like like you
got attacked by a shark but now you swim
with sharks
see it's the opposite of i think what i
would do which is
if i get attacked by a shark yeah cool
lesson learned
the natural black mama would be a hard
pack like why am i doing this
yeah but but so do you is it just like
in a is it
for you just an adrenaline thing or is
it for something where you're like i
just have never done it so i'm gonna do
it i just figured i'm australian
yeah yeah what animals love yeah when i
was a kid i gave a
strange dog a hug because we weren't
allowed to have pets in my house my
parents had four crazy kids so no dogs
so i'm pretending this dog is my friend
and it's my dog showing off to the other
kids to look cool
and i went to give it a hug goodbye and
i just went ah ripped my
whole nose apart are you an animals man
they don't mess with them yeah i'm so
tasty but but with that
snake they were just trying to like it
was teaching a lesson
no it was part of this oh just to
demonstrate what the rangers have to go
up against what they have to do when
they hunt
when they're going after the poachers
right yeah and you say they were
arresting him the poachers though
obviously armed with weapons yeah are
the posters shooting at you
we didn't encounter any armed poachers
when i was there but if the poachers
start shooting they
shoot to kill like they'll shoot back
jesus and are the people who are hunting
the poachers like
this dude that you're talking about he's
a trained what's his passion
he used to be a clearance diver like me
then he went to the tactical assault
group as a sniper with the special
forces
then he got out of the military and he
did two sorry 12 tours of iraq
and so he was working as a military
contractor out there and then he was
training the local government soldiers
so poachers ain't [ __ ] to him it's not
like they're like full-on man like that
the poachers aren't
they crept into the villagers and
they've killed a bunch of his rangers in
their homes
there's a bounty out on his head these
poachers are ruthless and they're all
funded by the chinese
uh partially by the europeans as well
but it's the china it's the asian
marketplace
what is it is it rhino horizon yeah yeah
they're hacking the faces off of these
rhinos and that's what ultimately led
damien there he was there on a break
from iraq he was doing a safari
and they came across a rhino with his
whole head hacked off and he's like my
skills can be better used here so
ham moved there over the course of many
years he
utilized his paramilitary training and
started the anti-coaching foundation
so the chinese are funding these
poachers just because they want the
horns of the dinosaurs yeah so these
poachers will get maybe
200 bucks and we're on our horn is worth
more than gold
and heroin once it gets to its final
destination yeah they're only in two
what are they using it for
they need a manager medicine medicine
that doesn't do anything no it's
[ __ ] it's made of keratin same [ __ ]
as that thing they think it's an
aphrodisiac like they think same with
shark fins it doesn't do anything
wait wait are you saying i could get
money from my fingernails pretty much
yeah
i mean listen times are tough you know
yeah right
torn's down yeah how much am i getting
for one
good fingernail i don't know how much
heroin is but it's worth more than that
i gotta tell you because my toenails are
thick
are these poachers well trained oh
they're not well trained but they are
native bushmen
okay so they've never known they've been
hunting their whole lives so they're
known and i'm assuming that
if you're only getting paid 200 for
something that is worth
way more than that that means you need
that 200
yeah yeah it's called subsistence right
yeah right right
and that 200 goes a very long way when
you're
living in africa in the wild that it's
such an interesting thing because and
obviously anti-poaching but i bet you if
you ask the poachers they'll be like
we're feeding our families yeah yeah 100
i know that's such a dichotomy situation
you know
right yeah but at the same time we've
got they've got to protect this is their
vital resources
their heritage they look at them as
their family and so they that's why
they're willing to risk their lives to
go out there and
how big a area because i'm assuming if
you're anti-poacher but that's a
huge area millions of square miles so
how do you narrow it down on where these
people are
and where they're hunting like how do
you follow them
[Music]
damian said the great thing about the
women is that um
they're fighting not just for the
animals they're fighting for their homes
their families
whereas the guys would get called in
from all different areas of of africa
that spend their their payment on booze
and hookers whereas the women are
reinvesting into their families
reinvesting into the villages
they're incorruptable apparently one of
his main guys that i worked with ended
up
getting corrupted the women incorrupt
defined corruption yeah
um basically selling off information to
poachers and poaching leaking
information leaking information yeah
and the good thing about women is they
love to gossip so they
are incredible at intelligence gathering
oh they're interesting yeah
but with this women this documentary my
wife is going to think she's intelligent
right
but these women you can use that better
yeah yeah these these women this
documentary they're not
fighting the poachers oh yeah look at
that picture man
she's strapped with a m16 i'm not even
trying to be mean i thought those were
men
no they're they're they're women that is
crazy that's an m16
yeah so and so how long has he been over
there
sure man um it's got to be nearly 20
years
yeah he built it from the ground up he
came back to australia sold
a bunch of his investment properties
that he bought with his uh deployment
money
and started this moved out there and
went in wholehearted
he's an incredible guy and so anyway the
reason i went vegan was because i was
out there working with him oh yeah you
went vegan yeah
and what was it about being out there
that made you
like why was it just you like these are
amazing animals like because i know a
lot of people
they'll see documentaries on how animals
are treated in like
like chickens yeah yeah yeah what was it
about being out there with those massive
animals
damien being a massive hero in the
military world back in australia
uh i have a lot of respect for him and i
saw him eating
one night he had a separate pot and i'm
thinking oh this
this [ __ ] he's saving the good
meat for himself and the range is the
[ __ ]
so i hit him up he's like oh i don't eat
meat the the rangers eat meat i'm like
what do you mean you don't eat meat he's
like one vegan like
what's that and he's like i don't eat
any i'm like why
he said well i was going out to work
every single day to try and protect
these animals and then i was coming home
and i was eating a dead animal and i
felt like a hypocrite and that kind of
struck a chord with me because in the
military
your leaders if they're poor leaders
they're hypocrites they
uh they live by the doers i say not as i
do and that's not a good leader and i
want to
perpetrate being a good leader in
everything i do and so i hate hypocrites
and so i went home
and i thought you know what i'm going to
do this i'm going to go vegan and i
lasted three days
i've been there better me i lasted eight
hours eight hours
in between meals bro i know i was like
what the [ __ ] do i have a headache
but they're healthy carbs yeah dude i
eat so much i love
i love eating and i can eat as much as i
want anything i want to know i'm vegan
yeah
has your body changed you seem to
actually be in better shape now
than you were i kind of and because i
don't get any injuries
i don't they reckon there's inflammation
attached to
dairy products and eggs and all that
sort of stuff i don't know i'm not a
scientist
all i know is i haven't had an injury in
four years like no tendinitis no like
nothing i'll tell you for me um and i'm
i'm like
90 percent plan
i have meet every now and then just
because honestly when i'm on the road or
when i'm out with old friends
yeah and i don't want to do the whole
explanation i'm like i'll have a piece
of whatever tonight maybe a piece of
fish
but when i am clean clean clean my and
i'm old man
my aches and pains daily aches and pains
are gone
because it is inflammation for me it's
all about
what it does my bo my stomach isn't
bloated
yeah there's no inflammation in mine
that makes sense it's just a beast to do
it's hard the disciplines it's really
not once you get used to it i don't even
think about it anymore
and i've been there with the traveling
and stuff it's you know going through
three
multiple airports in one day and yeah
like texas and arizona you're like there
is
nothing to eat here yeah so i pack some
bars and stuff like that now i've had to
go hungry but
you know some people think that that
would make you want to change so you can
eat
but actually what it does for me is it
it makes me more driven
to not give in to stick to it yeah you
tell me when you were in texas and at a
barbecue place you you weren't like
you don't have any jackfruit barbecue
actually you'd be surprised mate
a lot of them do yeah yeah but sometimes
uh
um i just get a whole bunch of the sides
i don't really care it doesn't it's not
that important to me to have to eat meat
i'd like i'd rather
not have the animal die and just live a
life trust me i know what it's like to
be eating it sucks
this fair point now the listeners are
just
yeah listening yeah yeah you you have a
what would you call it by
robotic prosthetic leg six
microprocessors
accelerometer due to a ball stroke is
that correct yeah bull shark
in sydney harbour when i was in the navy
for me man one of the big
and you and i met when i was doing that
shark after dark mm-hmm
and that's shark week discovery yeah and
by the way
that was the tara read episode which is
on right now actually shark week's on
it's on right now we're in shark week
right now yeah are you just doing media
non-stop or not pretty much yeah i did a
couple of hours this morning i did three
hours back
21 interviews um by zoom yes are you
sick of it
absolutely because it's just i got to
tell the same story over and over and
over again like i don't mind talking
about the shows
but me having to retell the show
backstory over and over and over and
over
you know it's a pain in the ass but at
the same time it's important to get that
across because it's part of my message
overcoming adversity
you know embracing change improvise
adapt and overcome all that sort of good
stuff that i talk about
you know i might be doing one in
cincinnati and then there's one down in
florida and so these are the
the first time these people have ever
heard me tell that story but is it is it
only
a grind during shark week yeah yeah it's
the biggest grind during shark week
but uh you know the in the shark week
still doing like
to me i'm like how many how many how
many videos can they get of great whites
biting them
like that how do they keep their keys i
know but to me it's like i can't believe
they they're the best at it because it's
like
how much footage do they give these
[ __ ] sharks how many different spins
can they do on the shark they're
learning more and more every year
sciences so my show that's on tonight
uh great white double trouble looks at
the two genetically different
populations of great white sharks that
scientists have discovered there's a
population on the east coast and there's
a population on the south and west coast
and they don't cross into each other's
territory there's a
underwater land bridge between melbourne
and tasmania that
eons ago was out of the water but the
sharks i guess because of instinct don't
cross that land interesting and they
travel down
past tasmania and meet in new zealand
but they
don't cross-breed the crips yeah
really so we looked at that we looked at
which ones are more deadly which
why but that's the thing i mean i did it
for two years and the difference and i
asked the same question second year i'm
like
what are we doing yeah and they said
yeah but there's still so much for us to
learn
we're learning how they made where they
made where they
were getting better we tested out a
shark proof wetsuit this year
we remember we did that we did the show
it was incredible it really was
we did that chain mail thing the week of
the year i was on
i told you about that it's heavy right
oh it was so
[ __ ] 35 40 pounds yeah yeah we
had mike tyson in it this year didn't
might take some fighter shark
no i taught him how to knock it out
without using his fists
flip it upside down well over
stimulating the nose the ampu-live
lorenzini it's uh sensory perception
tools so you can you can flip it over
and i've done that but
by tickling the nose uh you can put it
what kind of shark did he do it on he
did it on a caribbean reef shock just so
you know there's a part of my body that
if you tickle i'll roll over to
really speak it brother yeah
yeah the the the marketing on the mike
tyson thing because it showed him like
you know dragging the chaos and i was
like i don't know if i'm into this yeah
it was click bait mate it was really it
was really i'm sure people tuned in
dude it was we got such great feedback
what do you find when people
go and haven't been in front of those
massive
creatures when they come up like all
these avi you've you've
done it with will smith and now i'm like
yeah is there a comp because
these are all immensely um
successful confident people have
dominated every aspect of their lives
is there a commonality when they come
out after they touch a shark or swim the
shark that they're like
it's almost a little more humility or
like you know what they're different
every time
ronda rousey could not get enough she
loved it there is a reason that woman is
an
absolute world champion in everything
she does right she processes information
she takes it on board she listens
listens and implements it yeah
which was important because i was
teaching her how to hand feed a bull
shark
and so dude those are the aren't they
the most they have the most testosterone
of anything in the world yeah uh-huh
bull sharks and tiger sharks or no bull
sharks bull sharks yeah
pound for pound they have the strongest
bite as well jesus christ yeah
and then so she was amazing will smith
was great
but once he we got the job done once he
you know pushed a tiger shark up over
his head
he cut it and he left and then we had
mike
and he had a whole journey to go through
and he was so terrified
i came up after one dive he was pulling
off his mask as he was throwing up pink
stuff all over the back of the boat
he was terrified and so working with him
was great because he was
scared the whole way through yeah and at
the end he finally
came on board he's like that was one of
the greatest things i've ever done in my
life
that's cool now in comparison i've also
worked with on one show we had joel
mchale adam devine
rob riggle anthony anderson and damon
wayne's jr
what happened working with comedians
underwater girl's great it's like trying
to herd mosquitoes
anthony anderson nearly died
so yeah anthony anderson was in this
like yellow submersible thing where his
head's just out of the water
and so the diver took him down and he
you
okay kind of gave him a thumbs up and
anthony gave him the go
up signal but he thought he was saying
yeah i'm good anthony's ears were nearly
exploding so he ducked out of the
submarine and
swum all the way to the surface which is
really dangerous
no the bends is different the bends is
where your body absorbs a certain amount
of nitrogen and then you come up too
quickly and the gas in your blood
expands so why was his dangerous
because he was swimming rapidly from the
bottom to the surface
in a shark area and so obviously sharks
are attracted to their predatory nature
and they'll pursue something that is
erratic and swimming away investigating
it for food that's what andy told me
andy casagrande a great guy a great
underwater
photographer cinematographer so he
i asked him i remember i asked on the
show i said well what what's the
deal if you're swimming up to the
surface and a shark because they will
they are predatory but they like to come
up from underneath yeah
that's how they and he said you got to
turn around and swim at it because it's
not
used to anything and i was like that's
not my instinct he said exactly yeah
yeah don't you andy told me the best
thing and i always tell this to everyone
don't act like food and they won't treat
you like food yeah he said swim at it
because
nothing in the ocean swims at a shark
but here's my thing with that for a good
reason
here's my thing here's my thing with
those shark experts have we ever seen
anyone swim at the shark like a great
white and be successful
because they said the same thing with a
bear have you heard this story they go
you see a bear you get big and taunts
yeah hold your bag above your head
and have you seen what happened with the
the cub scout leader no you get all the
scouts behind them and there's and they
just
stumbled upon a beer and yellow grizzly
bear and the bear goes oh cool and he
goes kid sit tight
i know what to do i have my training i'm
a i'm an eagle scout grown man
eagle scout so he gets all loud and goes
at the bear and the bear goes cool story
dude
i'm gonna eat your ass first in front of
all your cub scouts no way hate them
alive
oh my and then the science is like yeah
i'm an eagle scout really i'm a [ __ ]
bear yeah right yeah
i don't know what that or it's like with
the mountain lions the those guys in
seattle they're riding their bike and
see them outline they go you know get
big scared away so these two guys got
big and put their bikes over their head
and mountain lion was like
oh cool fellas and then ate the other
one alive while the other one ran off
and while the other one was running went
hold on buddy yeah and attract him no
that was a real hannibal lecter move i'm
going to kill you just slowly but let me
go get this easier
did you see the video yesterday of that
family
out at the park feet had the bear sit at
the table
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches yeah
what that's the dumbest
[ __ ] group that's a what a bear yeah
dude
right here it's some white did you know
that some white people should say this
they they
look what the they're feeding it it's
is that the dumbest thing you've ever
seen in your life how quickly
we talked about how quickly jon jones
could get rid of 10 people
this isn't a setup no dude dude they
don't like that's not like they're bear
and i don't like how cold
they are either oh oh my god this is
what country is this in
oh that has it seems russian it seems
man i'll tell you one thing i have a
four-year-old son
and i got my unagi scooter
sent to the studio i brought it home me
and him have been riding this thing like
a madman
unagi scooters it's portable stand-up
electric scooter
it's super light it's pretty powerful
man and it's fast it's only 26 pounds
one click it folds up so i put in the
garage has a
decent uh range 15 miles you know 20
miles
an hour so i'll see that range depends
how fast you're driving
but it's pretty fun man it's uh the
build quality is ridiculous it looks
sweet
it was named the best all-around
electric scooter by cnet just won first
place for best electric scooters
of 2020 by tom's guide so tom thinks he
knows what he's doing all right
this is the device that fixes the future
of commuting in this age of covid
um personal transportation without risk
of public subway
buses uh shared ubers forget about all
that get this fly ass scooter it's like
having your own magic carpet
you can get your own unagi scooter right
now go to unagiscooters.com
unagi scooters.com it's basically the
tesla scooters thing looks fly
drives fast kiddos love it i put them on
it i don't know if that's safe but i
still do it
you can use the promo code t-fat k for
150 off your
own unagi e500 while supplies last
again that's unagi scooters.com
unagiscooters.com
promo code t-fat k for 150 off your own
unagi scooter
listen kid now is the time to get your
student loan payments under control
you could be saving by refinancing your
student loans with earnest
you guys need to check in with
refinancer with earnest could help lower
your monthly payments
checking in takes just two minutes is
your student loan payment
super crazy high well ernest can help
you guys out by lowering your monthly
payment interest rates have hit record
lows which means it's a great time to
refinance your student loans
and see if you can lower your monthly
payment right now if you've been making
the same monthly payment
on your student loan for the last couple
years odds are you could reduce your
payment and save by refinancing
with earnest even if you refinance
before we got you man today's low rate
environment could really help you guys
checking your rate is fast it's easy to
start
complete a few quick questions online it
takes only two minutes
then you get a personalized rate
estimate without affecting your credit
score
want to change your monthly payment we
got you man earnest makes it easy
plus the internet loves earnest customer
service they're rated 9.4
out of 10 on trustpilot so
you can get a hundred dollars cash bonus
when you refinance a student loan with
earnest dot com slash fighter
terms conditions apply that's a hundred
dollars for free when you refinance a
student loan at earnest.com
fighter terms condition apply 100 cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com
fighter visit earnest.com fighter for
more details
terms conditions apply earnest student
loan refinance loans are made by earnest
operations llc and mls number
four nine one 1204917 california
financing law license number
six zero five four seven eight eight
three oh three second
street suite 401 and san francisco
california
nine four one zero seven visit earnest
dot com slash license for full list of
license states again
that's ernest.com fighter
it's so bananas to me so do we have any
evidence someone
seen a great white and swimming at it we
do it all the time
oh you guys yeah we do it all the time
all right it was shark screen so i had
to do uh
a show year before last called uh laws
of jaws 2 and we're testing out the
blood theory you know we all hear that
sharks can smell a drop of blood in 10
000 leagues of ocean and so we drained a
half a liter of my blood
out on the back of the boat and i jumped
off the back of the boat swum out and i
ripped open the bag and i had this big
plume of my own blood around me and
there was tiger sharks bull sharks
hammerheads lemons
didn't do a single thing and then so as
i was swimming back in they threw
a bucket of fish blood off the back and
they all went crazy and i had to swim
through that
and i was just pushing them off as i go
and the secret is you've got to be a
bigger bad a predator
but you didn't meet it with aggression
with aggression but you show them that
you're not scared and you're a predator
then they give you that respect oh wait
wait i have so many questions
okay so what's the difference between
being aggressive
and being a bigger predator you know it
seems like
we're talking about the same well if
you're aggressive then you're punching
it
right or you're jabbing it with a stick
you're only what happens if there's a
dog barking and you start jabbing it
with a stick or start trying to kick it
it's going to get yeah it's going to
attack you it's going to want to beat
you same as with sharks you know
these are wild unpredictable animals
like you never know 100 percent
like the bear stories of you know eating
the
scout leader's butthole
i might have made up he ate him ass
first but he killed it
he killed them
what i want to know is when when
discovery is going you know so this
shark week will finish
and then you know for next year is it is
there like a writer's meeting like you
guys
and are you in on it like right next
year what are we looking at someone's
like
no let's take his blood at certain
points through the year i just get the
given these stories and usually it's
discovery channel trying to kill me yeah
was there ever
was there any safety precautions set up
around you slimming and blood was there
were there other diverse insurance
policies yeah they're
uh yeah i wouldn't want to be paying for
that you know um
i had two divers on the bottom uh safety
divers but
what are they gonna do nothing you can't
do anything it's unpredictable yeah you
better
i don't think there's any other show on
television where people are literally
risking their lives every time we shoot
it's just have you ever seen uh what was
the show i loved
uh chin i think it was uh discovery
you got cancer you guys that the two
guys that got bit by all the animals is
like pain
kings of pain yeah and they went through
the like top ten animals went all over
the world would you do that
dude the finale they get a bow
constrictor they caught in the jungle
and they put their arms out for the boat
constrictor and [ __ ] with it it
[ __ ] these guys up so bad man did you
see the guy who also does the murder
hornet and all the he does the
the ten that big that's these guys but
on steroids
you're talking about my boy uh coyote
petersburg yes coyote yeah
is great these guys they're like uh you
know
do they get bit they're just like
jackass with animals the [ __ ]
out they do uh they do a scorpion fish
they plant their hand the scorpion fish
they do the you know restrictors have a
rows of teeth
yeah dude his elbow gets destroyed
oh no just right there they actually got
it's it's their it's on history
why one season only i know why like i go
into my stuff
and i don't try to you're trying not to
treat me exactly these guys
this is madness it was a great show
though so entertaining i got [ __ ] up
i can't even imagine like wanting to
know
what that feels like although i will
tell you i got um
tear gassed over a couple months
because i was down on beverly during the
protests and they and they shut off the
the tear gas and i was like i should run
back to my house but then i was like
when am i ever going to get a chance to
see what tear gas is like
so i walked right up into it i was like
that was a bad idea yeah
but awful it is just i i think it's
worse for some people than for others
yeah we get gassed and
uh pep sprayed in the military and it
affects people differently yeah for my
younger brother
so they put you in this brick room and
then they put on the the
tablets of what they call cs gas
it's one of the most powerful um tea
gases you can get
and then you've got you go on your gas
mask and they say all right everyone
take it off and then you've got to say
your name your rank and your number
and my brother's in there everyone else
is spluttering coughing begging to get
out my brother's just standing there
like nothing's wrong oh damn it
waving in the window didn't do anything
to him for taste weird some people
it's that way with tasers too you know i
got tased in shreveport louisiana
um we protesting again
yeah so there used to be a funny bone
down there
and on the the local cops who wore like
orange vests they were different
they they would come in on thursday and
go hey we tased the headliner at the end
late show saturday and i thought it was
oh you don't i was like yeah ha ha ha ha
ha ha
ha ha
ha ha
ha ha
ha ha ha ha i get approval for that yeah no
approval
this was a few years back you saw nuevo
and no oh
and they kept saying and i asked the
people who worked there i'm like but
what and they go no they come back i
said so every comic
has been tased and they go no paulie
sure wasn't tased because he left before
saturday late show
there's no way this is on stage that has
come up
after the show everybody was gone
definitely illegal
and um they got me they said do you want
to take the
or the the zit and they got me with the
zit
and it hurt like it wasn't great man it
was not great at all
i did you wet yourself no but i asked
them i go does everybody and they say
some people
in none of the comics but they say you
can shoot some people with that taser
and it just doesn't yo we've seen those
cops
yeah yeah that's true yeah meth is a
hell of a drug but but yeah i
i those type of things when you see them
like the same thing with the tear gas
i've always wanted to know but now that
i know
i don't want to know i don't need to
know you're not curious at all
no not really i'm so i've been
electrocuted
like with hard static electricity and i
don't want you know yeah when you rub
your feet on the carpet yeah
like one of one of my uh bucket list
things is to see a great white in the
ocean like go in the cage and do all
that but that
come with us
yeah we go to guadalupe island sail out
of san diego we got a trip in october
we got four spaces left really yeah what
do i have to do though
nothing you can do whatever you want
it's all free food all
for all diets all free wine and beer on
the boat
gotta get trained before we go no
nothing nothing you don't even have to
be dive qualified because it's surface
diving
so all you do is you put on your weight
belt we give you a mask and a regulator
you jump off the back end of the cage
we had uh footage from our last trip
last year ended up on the news across
america the 16-foot female attacked one
of the pontoons on the side of the cage
and her whole body is just shaking this
whole cage three girls in there
not even panicking had their cameras out
trying to get closer oh i would care
you know i the one thing that i saw the
last time i did shark week which was
amazing to me i guess i
i always thought that the the sharks
were more instinctual than they were
intelligent
but there they did this show where they
put three people in a cage
and one person in a cage and i was like
oh the shark is going to attack the
three people because it's more food
and all the sharks went to the loan
easier easier it's probably
it's smaller so it's going to create
less harmful smaller
that's what they were like smaller
easier
he was in a one-man cage and that shook
the whole bit a whole
chunk out of the inflation christ yeah
man i i i'm
i'm in awe of it i definitely would like
to do i would love that
i i because it's one of it's a huge fear
for me there is
nothing you can do in this world that
will replicate doing that
like neither feeling no other sensation
nothing it's incredible
you've touched the great whites you've
swam out out of the cages with them yeah
yeah me and andy did it we did a show
called return to the island jaws we
dropped a cage this is in like the
middle of nowhere australia it's really
small town attached to it when like
three hours offshore
we had a two-person cage and we dropped
it all the way to the bottom
uh it was about 110 feet lifted up the
side we counted seven different great
white sharks on the way down
and then we we open up the cage door and
andy's like all right i'm going to get
out so i can get some
better oh he's a maniac he's a maniac
he's like all right bro you got to watch
my back
dude he's andy's swimming with a camera
so he's not protected
so he pushes him away with the camera i
got a gopro on a stick
i'm 30 feet away from the cage
surrounded by four great white sharks
swimming directly at my head
and i got a gopro and a stick and at
that point you kind of just relinquish
all control
and you enjoy it huh yeah it's kind of
fun you love it yeah
yeah i'm because you've been doing it
how long oh man
i've eight years i think something like
that since i think i did my first
interview in 2012
and they did my first co-hosting job
with andy 2014. i feel like 2014 was
when we met maybe yeah
yeah that was my first year they flew me
out like
i hadn't even been on a show now you're
like the you're the shark guy
i'm one of them people on there there's
some
like christine zanato and jamin
martinelli i think her name is
these two chicks man are the best shark
handlers in the bahamas
dickie still doing it did you still do
it now to south africa yeah yeah dickie
it was this young
crazy kid he shot this video where he
was like he wanted to
he wanted the shark to attack this
little
paper thin shark looking thing that he
was floating on
he wanted to see he wanted i wanted they
wanted the shark to swim up next to it
to get an accurate size but
he was yeah floating on this thin piece
of balsa wood basically
something he's he's mad absolutely
insane but all those videos you see on
social media
on facebook and stuff of the person in
the chain mail
removing all the hooks and flipping up
the sharks upside down that's christina
that's that's
and jamin that's two chicks there's
probably a handful of you guys though
you know what i'm saying this is not
like a [ __ ] ton of people are trying to
do all the shark work no
most of the the good at it i mean the
really good ones are all
part of the the eco tourism so uh stuart
coves out of the bahamas there's a hot
couple out of the bahamas
uh there's a few out of fiji that's
where we took ronda and taught her how
to hand feed bull sharks
what's left on the insane list that you
that's still on your bucket list like
you seem to have you've kind of done it
all yeah i don't know
um how's this yeah that threw me out of
a plane
two years ago fifteen thousand feet
directly into the ocean to survive for
44 hours no food no water surrounded by
sharks
this was undiscovered yes yeah i missed
that one what yeah
so we did uh we did a show uh three
years ago called
um shark wrecked and they blew up our
boat me and the british special forces
guy
i blew up our boat to signify you know
so many people
get trapped out at sea uh also it was
um to demonstrate the largest shark
attack in history which was the uss
indianapolis and the philippine sea
of 300 sailors eaten by oceanic white
tip sharks
how how long was that oh man world war
ii
um and so we were semi-replicating that
a little bit but we couldn't do it out
there
because commercial fishing had wiped out
the populations you know so it was an
underlying message there we had to do it
in the bahamas
44 hours surrounded by oceanic white tip
sharks known as the wolves of the sea
um and no food no water and so the next
year they had to up the ante
and what we did was we i had to get
parachute train like i've done static
line
in the army but i've never done free
fall so i had to get free floor licensed
and then parachute directly into the
ocean off the coast of palau which is a
pacific island known for some of the
heaviest fighting in world war ii
george bush senior was shot down there
and so we're
semi replicating what would happen if a
pilot was shot down and had to survive
and so that was crazy as well but i
nearly died
where were you floating were you just in
sea yeah the first night
as sun went down they dropped off what
the pilots would have had
a small inflatable four-man raft uh two
of us could just fit in it
and we're in that all it was honestly it
was worse than being in the ocean
we were curled up in like a yin and yang
together and it was raining and it was
windy
somehow james had this little dome over
his head i had this
plastic roof in my face oh [ __ ] night
it was
maddening and so i got no sleep i'm
super testy and then we got another
day and a whole nother night going into
that second night is the worst because
you get you know you've got
eight full hours of total darkness
sharks everywhere
and you just are things bumping your
boat yeah yeah i woke up but we're
the first on the first show on the first
night we had this by the way how big are
we talking about but like
are you um a little bit bigger than that
table oh my god yeah and so that sunk
this
that morning and then the next night we
didn't have it but we had this like um
cube metal with nets around it and i
woke up i was kind of drifting in and
out of sleep my head was on the metal
edge
and i woke up to this boom what the
boom the whole cage is shaking i'm like
no way that's a shark and then a fin
comes up next to my face and goes down i
was like
oh i'm not sleeping but no one got
attacked or anything
they came at us but we did what we're
trying to do just push them away show
them you're a predator
so they were constantly investigating us
especially when they started throwing
bait into the water wait a second
when you say she's investigating
investigating so they'll come up curious
because i had heard that first a lot of
times before they attack you they'll
come up and kind of
jump bump yeah but don't let them bump
you twice is what i was told well don't
let him bump you once if you can help it
because you never know when a bump's
going to turn into a nibble
so you just got to be careful man
they're wild animals the great part
about sharks is though
there is no other apex predator on earth
that will let you
share its space except for perhaps a
black bear in russia
but if you have peanut butter and jelly
yeah exactly yeah
or wyoming but yeah yeah but you can't
you can't run across the savannah
expecting not to get eaten by a lion a
hyena jag
whatever or go out to north america and
not
expect a mountain lion's going to rip
your guts but a shark
great white tigers bull sharks all of
them
so many millions of people are terrified
of these animals
yet these are the ones that will let you
share that space with them
every day in santa monica i had andy
tell me
yeah because i was like man i'm scared
of sharks that's why i just go in the
water out in santa monica and he was
like
exactly he said he said if you've been
up in santa monica
up to your waist yeah you've been within
four feet of a shark
guaranteed absolutely yeah this is what
he said he said guaranteed because it's
from santa monica
up the california coast and it's the
juvenile great whites that are
out here in santa monica which is why
people don't die from the bites is that
right they're learning how to attack
yeah yeah and so but as soon as i heard
that i'm like well
yeah well they had a guy in santa cruz
die recently yeah um
which sucks and you know they're all the
way up through san francisco we know
we're up there up there around the um
what do they call that either the
farallon islands the devil's teeth
yeah huge great white sharks up there
and we were going to do a show
called our nuclear sharks i think now uh
up off the farallons the u.s navy sunk
one of the
bikini atoll testing warships where they
had it with doing the nuclear testing
this thing would be blasted with
radioactive waves
then they put 42 000
barrels of nuclear waste on it and sunk
the ship off the farallons
and some of the barrels were popping to
the surface so the sailors were shooting
them to get water into them to sink
obviously nuclear waste is coming out as
well so they want to do this show up
there looking into
if that has created some super
aggressive great whites but
apparently they're huge out there well
maybe it might have something to do with
the nuclear waste
yeah this four-headed shark i don't know
ninja turtles
octopus is real but so let me ask you
this might be you might like dude too
much but when you when they're like hey
so 44 hours in the ocean
no net you're gonna be you know you know
balls to butt with this guy
on the ocean nothing do you get paid
more for that
no i know i know
our contract's up this year i'm asking
for a raise by the way you have to yeah
because is it is it just across the
board if you're doing that
or you're just doing something fun you
get paid the same look i've got to agree
to it yeah i'm on contract with
discovery channel so i get paid a
certain amount per show i do three shows
a year
brandon i don't know three shows a year
yeah i don't know if you're familiar
with
cable they don't exactly have the
deepest pockets in the world
discovery channel does discovery they
have to because they're
putting you in the ocean with great
white shirts yeah these shows we shoot
are really expensive to make anything on
the ocean is hard oh dude you got
underwater cameras
yeah it's the whole stack yeah exactly
and then again there's not a lot of
people to your defense there's not a lot
of people can do it
no no there's a plethora of scientists
they could bring on board
and i think that's one of the things
that they they need to do more of there
hasn't been a great
matrix of uh race and sexual diversity
like we didn't
have many i haven't seen all the shows
this year but they're telling them
women scientists on it which is
something like i've worked with women
scientists on shark week shows in the
past but i didn't notice that many this
year yeah is there a lot though
to their defense there's plenty there's
plenty yeah we have yeah absolutely
they obviously in anything that you do
you can always do it a bit better and
every year you learn a little more so
hopefully they'll take it on board but
also you need to not just be a scientist
you need to be good on camera
yeah so some of the people men and women
that we've already had on camera are
terrible
most scientists don't become scientists
because they're good on cameras
so that was the problem with getting
guests for the show they were like we
had a scientist but nerd alert
he can't say for words yeah it's a very
different feeling to talking
talking about what you know in front of
someone as soon as you put a camera on
someone
you know they just freeze up what's
going on he
he's the first year that i met him he
brought his two buddies to the
show with him and one of his friends
chris who may be the biggest
human i've ever seen really shout out to
chris
dude georgia dude's body
i i it's like like healthy big or like
he's got muscles on his hands yeah he's
huge he's six
for 340 pounds uh i think he's dropped
down to about 320 now his
arms are sorry like what's he doing he
was a
a navy seabee so um engineer for the
special forces out
out of coronado
great dude talks like this he's from
louisiana originally but you're another
friend
who we who you brought that first year
we were drinking in the green room
before the show
and he didn't he didn't mean oh that was
jimmy was it jimmy yeah he didn't make
it oh yeah jimmy
that night he was he left our hotel room
and
he didn't come back for an hour like
where the hell is jimmy we opened the
door
he's sitting at the outside the door on
his hands and knees almost in tears like
i
i was lost
like dude you got to calm down on the
drinking that was also the year tara
reed couldn't quite
understand why you had you were wearing
a glove yeah uh-huh
no matter how many times you were
laughing so hard at that i couldn't get
enough
you're so kind she couldn't work out how
a whale and a shark would make or make a
while
fantastic we watched a clip it's
fantastic
didn't you you said you went into a
dressing room and she was sipping a
bottle of wine then she'd take a blue
pill
yeah makes sense
yeah i was like this this this is going
to be a great interview yeah this is
just no way she's going to be awake for
this
but she was a pro she kept both eyes
open i mean where you going she said man
paul i love australia because
australians don't judge me they love to
party as hard as i can
i was like it's true they do she was
great man
oh did they they don't do they still do
uh shark after dark yeah josh gates is
doing it uh
via zoom calls at the moment so i did
mine with him
last night i think it was on uh yeah
it's been hard like i i'm
like you guys you guys get on stage and
do your shows i get on stage at
conferences and do motivational speaking
and it's just
every all the jobs have been cut by half
the pay has been cut by half but
you just keep doing it you do it by zoom
or whatever who do you feel like
because i i've watched clips of your
motivational
uh speaking and you told me before that
when you show
pictures of your injuries
that it's dudes who will throw up in the
audience that pass out
you show real like real footage i show
the footage of the shark attack i show
you the surgery
all of it so i've got i've got not just
photos of that you can it's on it's on
the internet can i tell you when we went
very far paul one of the craziest things
in my life and i've had been able to
interview people i interviewed bill
gates dude yeah
one of the craziest things was listening
to you as
we you and i were watching the shark
attack together
if you go to my youtube page uh i've got
some of those like little motivational
videos that i made and
with the pictures and then the video of
the shark attack and the pictures are on
youtube
i was like how can you watch this and
you were like it's like a completely
yeah different i had a very different
view yeah yeah yeah
yeah very good is this here someone else
uh yeah that's makeup yeah
but like it's so amazing that you can
watch but if you go
a little bit further down yeah i kind of
relish in it there's um
so little motivation yeah anything with
like the motivation or whatever there
yeah the picture is going up a fraction
this one
upper fraction to the next one i think
on the far right there
that's what that yeah next one up yeah
that should be in there somewhere okay
it's brendan it is gnarly yeah yeah i
might go
take a quick pay break yeah yeah yeah
yeah it is
absolutely gnarly man
but like i could i would want to just he
this is a different dude like if you
should look at that first picture we'll
be able to show this right chin
the song we can't do so i'll just show
that yeah listen man this weekend ufc
252
stipe dc it's happening my lock of the
week is
jds over rosenstrook watch the big fight
watch the nba watch nhl watch mlb watch
pga
soccer all the sports are booming and
you want to make money use draftkings
draftkings
has brought their ex expertise to
legalize sports
betting it's legitimate sportsbook based
right here in the us of a
draftkings america's top rated
sportsbook app is safe secure it's
reliable
you can deposit withdraw your money at
your convenience
uh this weekend new users bet a dollar
to win 252 bucks that's right place one
dollar
on either the main event for ufc 252 and
you have the chance to win 252
bucks can't beat those odds new users
get a sign up bonus up to a thousand
dollars so head right now to the app
check out all they have to offer
including player props live betting so
much more
all right download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app right now use
the code
fighter when you sign up for a limited
time all new users can get a signup
bonus up to a thousand bucks that's
right
draftking sportsbook has a signup bonus
up to a thousand bucks
just enter the code fighter when you
sign up only at draftkingsportsbook
and bet on ufc 252 this saturday must be
21 or older new jersey indiana or
pennsylvania
only bonus comprised of first deposit
bonus and first bet match each up to 500
deposit bonus requires 25 times play
through restriction supply
craftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or in
indiana check 1 809 with it
and that's what i'm up we were talking
about going places or hanging out at
parties or gatherings where there's
really successful people
and for me one of the reasons i started
doing it and i hated doing it at first
because i'm like
[ __ ] these pretend book but then my
brother was like
you want to be successful go hang out
with the successful people
yeah and pick their brains and what do
they all have in common and we start to
realize these are a couple traits that
all these people have in common like you
can't get me to a party
really it doesn't mean like a party till
2 a.m it might not be in your wheelhouse
it's not something you need to achieve
but me moving out here being little paul
de gelda from australia i wanted to meet
these
people and so by putting my and i'm i'm
an introvert like i love being i love
being invited to stuff and being able to
say
no i'm good just going to hang out
unless you've got some sharks some bombs
or something
i'm not really that interested yeah i'm
a homeless you came to our house man
yeah it was from my wife's
party yeah it was a great party your
house is beautiful i love that sitting
room with the bookshelf
you live where marina del rey oh nice
yeah and so i
forced myself to get outside of my
comfort zone and i swear to god some of
the people i've met
at these you know they're not parties
they're events right um
unbelievable people that have become
very good friends like tulsi gabbard
um steve bellamy who runs kodak film
like so many
like just incredible people and a party
guy either but
no i've i've events where i'm like all
right i should there are some people
there that i would love to pick their
brain
or meet or make a contact with that i
i definitely made a more concerted
effort to do because
like i said man when you're around a
room full of wildly successful people
you're if you're paying attention learn
something yeah
yeah i get to go to dinner with um i
don't know if you know uh support
sepultera sepultura yeah so the band yes
awesome the one at the lead singer i
think uh derek green
so i got to have dinner with him one
night at crossroads kitchen
and we got we were talking and i was
like it's a vegan place yeah yeah but
he's vegan
um that's travis barker's joint yeah
it's good food
i like it there but i was i couldn't
understand how
he made his voice do that and it's like
a alissa white from um
arcane arc enemy yeah how like have you
heard her sing
she sounds like a demon yeah really like
how do you make your voice do that he's
like you gotta do these warm-ups
i'm like can you show me he's like i
don't want to freak everyone out and i'm
going to do it don't do it
i can't even give it justice man
everyone the
yeah man that yeah right there yeah who
would you say for you
out of all those did you get to pick
will smith's brain you tell me if you
had a chance to pick his brain you
wouldn't pick wilson experience
if you i'm just different if you tonight
said hey will smith's gonna be at
crossroads restaurant anywhere i
wouldn't drive no no but
that's all i'm asking if you had a
chance to pick this dude's brain
because he again is a wildly successful
dude who's been successful across a
bunch of different
platforms he's so yeah i love it but you
wouldn't be interested to just to pick
his brain or listen
he got invited i don't know i don't i
wouldn't go i don't know him that well
so you know it's weird like you don't
know somebody and then you're trying to
pick their brain like i think
i feel like it takes like uh like
there's levels to it you know you do it
through conversation
yeah it's practical yeah
i'm just so curious man especially
people i don't know
especially in fields that i don't know
anything about
i am so curious when i get when you add
all those up and you talk to a bunch of
different successful people from a bunch
of different fields and you're like wait
a second everybody basically took the
same first
four steps yeah there's a similarity
right everything that's the kind of
thing i'm talking about you're like
got it got it so to get to here they're
in different places now but they all
basically took the first same three or
four steps those are the kind of things
for me that are invaluable that i would
never be able to learn
no i wish i was moving and you've got to
be dedicated you've got to pour your
heart and your soul into it yeah that's
the the main step that they all have
they dedicate themselves yeah i also i
also i guess
i don't think there's anything i can
talk to will smith about where he's
going to say something and seem like oh
there it is like me little paul de gelda
from
canberra australia has anything in
common with him either but
it's that's the good thing about these
people he he gets to
show a human side of himself same with
mike tyson i got nothing in common with
him but
we hit it off like a house yeah brother
you i hate this you'd make it no matter
if you met mike tyson you know what i'm
saying like with your work ethic and
your brains you're going to make it
regardless brain's not so much he is
definitely i've done some damage yeah
what's interesting is i i thought uh
australia was booming as far as covert
they didn't get shut down or anything
but you were saying that there's like
they're pretty locked down man yeah
especially
um victoria so melbourne six-week total
lockdown almost martial law
police patrolling the streets finding
anyone that's not out for like
sydney's the same sydney's not as far as
i'm aware i think it was they had a huge
outbreak in melbourne so they shut down
the borders um i'm not
sure how the rest of the country is
faring but new zealand is killing it
they haven't had a single case in like a
hundred days can i just tell you that i
was blown away
i told you that blown away by new
zealand
me too without a doubt they're dublin
yeah the
dublin was amazing but new zealand first
of all the people
were so cool and when i was in uh
wellington
which is at their capital mm-hmm and
when you fly uh
and i was like what is it so crazy about
here it took me two days walking around
there was nobody walking around looking
at their phones
nobody was on their phones cafes people
were just talking to each other and i'm
like this
is so funny i remember i [ __ ] up
because i was doing stand-up there and i
got out
remember this chin i got out and i want
coffee and i thought i didn't know they
had different currency in
uh in new zealand in australia so i just
had all this
i just laughed at you yeah i just had
all this australian money i went to new
zealand to get a coffee and she's like
what are you doing
yeah yeah yeah what are you doing
shoot they like tore into me like oh my
bad and they got such a good sense of
humor
yeah i was like my man everyone that
goes to australia i tell them
while you're there go see new zealand it
is one of the most beautiful places
the most beautiful postcard beautiful
yes melbourne i will tell you though
i'll tell you the one thing i like about
it it had a very new york kind of energy
it's very cosmopolitan
but every time i said where's the best
so-and-so food
you know ultimately they always it
always ended with
and then go down the alley and in the
alley why are all your best restaurants
you
know
everything's in alley man everything is
because i guess because i was in
uh yeah you're like step over the
homeless dude
yeah sydney tried to copy it as well but
they're not doing as well
australia to me because i get you know i
was touring there so i was in the main
cities it just felt like uh
a cleaner america yeah it was just
everything was exactly the city man
unless you're going to somewhere like
prague
that has all these gothic castles and
all that like every city is the same
that's why you've got to get out of the
cities like you don't go to australia to
go to sydney yeah you go and ride the
ferry across the harbour and see the
bridge and the opera house
awesome then you go up to darwin then
you go see some crocodiles you go out to
western australia see some wildlife
that's the australia people yeah that's
so when i i didn't like on the menu they
called
uh seafood bugs oh that's a specific
that's a specific sort of it's called
the balmain bug yeah it's a specific
sort of uh
crustacean yeah they're delicious it's
like uh it's like lobster yeah
the same kind of uh consistency yeah
east coast lobster
oh i'm not familiar well because the the
the rock lobster which is called out
here
is a little tougher the main lobster is
that red mm-hmm
it's a it's definitely succulent yeah
this is that's a little tougher
yeah but while i don't promote eating my
friends
it's not like i was i wasn't doing it my
whole life
you know with mango sauce you know what
when i i remember when i texted you when
i was in australia and i was like what
should i do
and you sent me a whole list of stuff
i'm like i got three hours and you're
like yep
you're [ __ ] yeah three hours
three hours you got me free tickets for
my brother in melbourne yeah and i don't
even know if he went he didn't even say
thank you he didn't tell me
i mean he didn't go it was terrible and
he hates me
i must have wait i thought i'd get your
sister tickets maybe in sydney yeah
because your sister said thank you yeah
yeah my sister is awesome
she's one of the toughest chicks i've
ever met iraq veteran afghanistan
veteran oh jesus yeah
is that right army medic outside the
wire on five-week fighting patrols with
the two guys what does that mean
so you've got like the compound the base
right
and generally all them the medics
especially the females aren't allowed so
allowed outside that base because women
aren't allowed in combat roles
they are now they're pushing them
through into infantry and stuff like
that
but then no women were allowed in combat
roles and so she was one of the first
women to go
outside the wire in a war zone five-week
fighting patrols and she was with
the two guys my chief and my leading
seaman that saved my life
and they were the bomb disposable guys
and that was three months after my
attack
i mean so this is how much of a child i
am you said leading semen i had to try
not to laugh
yeah i'm like oh come on okay
can you use a different word than simon
i'm i'm a child always the first one to
get pregnant
they're leading i was just able able to
you're
i if i'm going to be a seaman i want to
be the leading scenario the leading i
don't want to just be an able
no you get lost in the jews
you're you're um nonchalant
nonchalant isn't the right word but
casual confident attitude
um obvious towards sharks is the real
reason that i'm like i think i can still
do this
because it frightens me but like you're
so casually
confident not a big deal yeah let's just
do it
every time i talk to him like yeah this
is actually just [ __ ] i have this
on oh how do i put it i have it
i have a quiet confidence that is
probably
not justified as much as i embrace it
put it that way
um i just believe that everything's
gonna be okay
and so far it's been okay yeah i think
that's the right
i got bitten on the hand once when i was
um diving with al roker and i was doing
uh some shark week publicity for him
and i i had but i had chain mail on my
sleeve and so i wanted to get this good
shot of feeding a
a caribbean reef shark and i held on a
little bit too long and i grabbed my
hand
and so that was the only the first time
i've ever had kind of a flashback
instant panic for a millisecond and then
i just let my hand go
and eventually it let my hand go and
obviously i had chainmail so it didn't
cut my skin or anything but it was kind
of a uh
a dawning of realization that i've been
pushing the boundaries pretty damn hard
the last few years and all it takes is
one bite like that
not wearing chain mail and my other hand
is rendered totally useless
and so now i i try and mitigate the
risks a little more
is there something i mean for both you
guys like is there something you're like
i'm definitely i know other people do it
but i'm not doing that's one thing i'm
not
not getting bitten by an anaconda so
you're not doing that you're not doing
that
but it's needless yeah it is you know
something that's worthwhile i would do
any of that stuff i'd do the great white
dive with him
but as far as anything like risky
working you're not an adrenaline junkie
not at all i'm not either and then
especially now that yeah i bet you're
not either but especially i have kids
like
everything to me is like risking them
you know right everything i'm like
looking around at everything yeah you
really
gotta take care of your family yeah
exactly and every day i post
damn every day because i bike every
morning those rattle snakes dude that
one tip was that today
that was yesterday yeah but i quit
posting because i see him so often
and so i used to take my son hiking on
that same trail i don't take him anymore
well you got to show me where that is i
want to take my camera up there
every day yeah it is crazy how how long
is that just so i
have uh an idea yeah i mean that's a
small one
that gets it was the first snake i've
ever saw when i started riding my bike
dude i thought it was an anaconda wow it
was [ __ ] i wonder if
you just eaten nope everyone keeps
saying that it's just a monster
his head was like this dude chin do you
have it it's probably i don't know
eight weeks ago you know what that that
you know anaconda was [ __ ]
when jacob was five he
he wanted a little ball python so i was
like the worst animal to have i go okay
i go but listen man
here's the deal no you can't take it out
of the cage by yourself
and he goes okay so the very first night
i come in to tuck him in bed and he's on
this top bunk
and i look in the cage and i go
where's the snake buddy and he goes i
don't know i go
where's the snake buddy and he lifts
pulls back his covers and he's just got
the snake sleeping
on his chest and i got dude on his
chest that is a [ __ ] no-go
dude my friend was trying to get rid of
a snake once and i was like yeah sure
why not i'll take it
yeah albino corn snake like really
beautiful red eyes
white and yellow tell me that's the
that's not the biggest rattlesnake
you've ever seen
that's hard to tell without something
next to it that is a shame
[ __ ] big it looks like a crocodile's
midsection
you're coming but you're you're right at
its head man how close are you right now
to that
i mean you know pretty close yeah when
it starts making that
s shape that's when yeah that's that's
i've watched enough
where i was like yeah he seems pretty
chill
yeah i i um i'm i'm not
for me my thrills like i'm not an
adrenaline junkie
but i want to
i don't want to say i don't like
something until i try it so like i
i i'm not going to get tear gassed again
i'm not going to get tased again
i may i want to swim the great white but
i can't tell you that i'll ever do it
again you know i mean i just want to i
want to i don't want to be rooted
i want to experience it i want to decide
for myself because i know
i have probably some fears that i don't
need to have
i bet you swimming in a cage with great
wife is one of those fears
it just seems like something that why
the [ __ ] would you want like i would
never until you go and do it
right yeah so we spend three days out
there constantly
and the last trip we had um 18 guests we
had 15 girls
most of them traveling by themselves and
one of the guys the oldest guy was a
father of one of the girls and he just
came because he didn't want his uh
daughter traveling through mexico alone
he spent more time in the cage than ever
everyone else together oh wow yeah he
didn't even go for the sharks and he
loved it so much he spent more time in
the cage see like would you
have you uh jumped out of a plane i have
not but i would never do that i i did
the bungee
in auckland i jumped off that space how
good is that
i gotta tell you um so this is super
embarrassing so i
my heights is probably my all-time
[ __ ] clincher same
so but i was like i wanna i wanna i
wanna conquer this
so the but the guy who was putting me in
the elevator on the way up i told him
i'm really scared i'm really scared
so they decided they were gonna [ __ ]
with me they knew i was a comic and he
put me in the elevator
and he go are you i go okay you coming
in he goes not just you
i go what and he goes yeah this elevator
is a really slow
ride up 700 feet and and the door is
shutting and he just was like have fun
and the door shut
and so i'm so scared of heights i pull
the blinds and the windows on the plane
like i don't want to look out there
[ __ ] i'm um so when we pull up out of
the ground
i see that the elevator is like 80 glass
and it's a slow ride because they want
you to get
have fun that's not fun for me so i
turned around and i blarewitched myself
i put my face against the wall and i
closed my eyes right
and i'm i'm so scared this is such a
[ __ ]
but i'm saying things like mom and dad
if you can hear me i just want you to
know
that you guys did a great job open up
and then you're just
and they're recording everything i
that's what i didn't know i have no idea
that they turn
on the videotape when you get so there's
like a 30 second elevator ride of me
being the biggest
[ __ ] and then it's just to get to the
top of it you just get to the top of the
bungee jump then you get to the top
and then you have to step off you have
to sign a waiver which didn't make me
too happy
i would never do that and then i but she
had to i was standing up there for so
long she goes look we gotta
you gotta go dude she goes we gotta go
and i said i don't know if i can jump
you're gonna have to push me and she
goes
i know and i was like what do you mean
you know she goes we watched your
elevator ride up i knew i was gonna have
to push you
she pushed how and how far how far is
that 16 seconds
there's a 16 17 second video of
me jazz handing and screaming like a
[ __ ] you know there's something about
bungee jumping that
is far more scary than parachuting why
do you
i know if it's because you're closer to
the ground and you can kind of see
everything that you would smash into
yeah or if it's because you're relying
on this rubber band to save your life
that's the one
but up in the sky everything's kind of
minute it's really far
kind of like oh i've got a parachute
i've got a reserve if something goes
wrong
and i did a accelerated freefall and so
you do your first jump by yourself
and so you do all the training on the
ground then you you instructors come out
they kind of hold these bits of your
suit but then they let you go
you pull your shoe and the most
dangerous part of it all is the landing
and you're doing that by yourself
i'm laughing out loud just trying to
steer myself having never done this
before thinking i'm gonna [ __ ] die i
have no idea what i'm doing
this is they should never have let me do
this
i had to do it for the show i had to get
through the training and then i nearly
died on the freaking
practice jump in palau it wasn't even
into the ocean so we pull up to palau
it's me and
james the british special forces guy and
we've got a jump master from like the
display team from the uk
military and they want to do a two jumps
together because we've never jumped
before so they'll hire this tiny little
plane
only two of us can fit in the door
together there's three of us max in the
plane
we get up to like 11 000 feet the wind
is 22 knots that's almost double what
i've ever jumped into before
as a learner you only jump into 14 knots
so we've got the strongest winds ever we
got this tiny little plane
the the landing zone where we're
supposed to land is a strip of grass
right next to the international airport
runway
on the other side of the landing zone is
a barbed wire fence off a cliff into the
jungle
and so we get up there and we might the
instructor the
jump master goes all right the door's
too small for the three of us so i'm
going to get out onto the wheel and i'm
going to hold on to the wing strut
and then you guys get into the door and
when it the lights on to go green
we'll all jump out together like oh all
right no worries we got all our
helmets and headcams and all that crap
on he gets out stands on the wheel grabs
on to the strut
me and james moving to the door and he
just drops like this the
jump master just drops down and we're
like so we look at each other grab each
other and fall out
and so because we haven't presented to
the wind it wasn't a controlled exit we
just start going
what do you mean like twist like you're
just spinning like and not like in
four dimensions like every direction you
can see it on the head cams and so we
realize we're out of control we let go
of each other and you can see me just go
and then disappear i can't get control i
don't know what i'm doing
all i know to do from my lessons is is
that is like
the standard mission impossible your
position you're and i'm just
some resulting or spinning both at the
same time
and so do you have any clue like yeah
nothing what about what's up and down
okay nothing you have absolutely no
control over everything all you see is a
blur
and so my alarm goes off in my helmet to
tell me i'm at 5000 feet which is when
we're supposed to pull
i'm still spinning if i pull my
parachute it'll wrap me up like a
burrito and i'll jam sandwich into the
ground
and so all i know is this and so i'm
just doing a more arch back arch back at
your back
four thousand feet still spinning three
and a half thousand feet still spinning
finally i stop and i see blue and i'm
thinking
what the hell we jumped over the jungle
why am i over the ocean
oh it's the sky punch my left hand flip
over
and the jungle is just coming at me so i
pull my parachute
and we're so low and because we fell out
early we're so far from the drop zone
i'm watching james tracking dirt roads
into the jungle just in case he lands in
the jungle we can go save him
but the 22 how far away were you from
james uh he was probably
500 feet below me uh and just
not far in front of me and so from my
position it looks like his feet are
skimming the the jungle canopy the whole
way
but the strength of the wind was in our
favor because it was pushing us towards
the drop zone so
at the end he didn't land on the drop
zone he had to lift his leg up legs up
over a cargo plane
um i got to the very base of the drop
zone
just in time turned into the wind but
because the wind was pushing me
towards the jungle cliff i've got one of
my my risers pulled all the way down the
other one all the way up to try and
account for the
the sideways track but i'm not going
anywhere i'm just
staying in one spot and all of a sudden
i get a gust of wind pushing me
backwards
into the international airport buildings
and so i'm freaking out thinking i'm
going to die it finally lets up enough
for me to drop down
right at the base of the drop zone oh on
both my feet
jesus and then the wind picked up my
parachute pulled me across the drop zone
oh that stressed me out dude the entire
story is good and then i had to do
one more and then to jump into the ocean
fast are you hitting the ground
uh it depends on the size of your
parachute when we do it with the
military which is the smallest
you'll land at 4.6 to 6.4 meters
a second which is kind of like they say
it's like jumping off a two-story
building
because those parachutes are designed to
get you from the plane to the ground
as fast as humanly possible
you can break your legs so many people
broke backs landed in trees
hit cows like cows hit cows is it is it
i heard
uh too for like bigger guys you can't
tandem jump because there's a certain
weight limit so yeah if you're over 225
you gotta do it by yourself yeah so when
we jump in the military
you would think you know you've got to
carry your ammo you're going to carry
your ammo your guns all that sort of
stuff
what they do is because they have a
weight limit on the parachutes the
smaller guys got to carry
all that weight for the bigger guys so
all of a sudden you've got this five
foot four dude carrying a
heavy machine gun 2 000 rounds of ammo
plus
all of his stuff and he just drops like
a rock oh
yeah yeah man i see it's the it's the
ability to think like that
and get your under pressure like [ __ ]
together that like chaos
i i was special forces i love it but no
i wasn't never special forces you're
under the department of the navy okay
yeah but but is it like there's no way
to tell i'm sure in your training or or
in
when you were in the uh a military there
are some people you're like this dude's
gonna respond under pressure and you
never know
and he was like the guy who did it yeah
right you never know until it
until [ __ ] until [ __ ] hits the fan right
yeah did you do
did you think you would be that person i
don't think you ever know until it hits
you like i never had to fire my gun in
anger
i was never in a gun battle it wasn't
until
the the shark attack that i really had
to pull my [ __ ] together
right and i think that's testament to
the training i i was
ready to die i was letting myself go to
die because i just figured that was it
but
then after the shark ripped out my
hamstring and ripped off my hand and i
popped to the surface
i had one job and that was get back to
the boat so i'm swimming
through the water one hand one leg
through a pool of my own blood
did not expect to make it i was just
waiting for this shark to come back and
finish me off but that was all i had to
do
one laser like focus get to the boat get
to the boat get to the boat guys got me
into the boat
all of their medical training came in
you know one of the guys had to stick
his hand inside my leg to pinch close an
artery
the guys like everything came together
so you know
that's the great part about the military
they train you for those intense
circumstances you told me that one of
your buddy this is him going on this is
uh so we have to warn the audience it's
kind of graphic yeah
this this video when i watched this with
you dude and how calm you were
i was blown away does it feel like a
different lifetime
you know what i mean it does yeah like
this is that chapter is so
far removed from where i am 11 years now
yeah but
i have to relive it so much that
it kind of becomes like i'm telling
someone else's story sometimes
i totally understand that and then you
know this is the surgery where step by
step where they removed my leg
so it's not just the shark attack but
the surgery photos because they had to
the problem was the shark could remove
my hamstring and so
if they removed above the wound they'd
cut all the way up below my hip
making me a hip disarticular amputee
makes walking getting prosthetics really
really hard
so what they did was they cut off my
foot they sliced open the back of my
calf muscle all the way to the bottom of
the shark bite
peeled all the flesh off the bone
removed the
the shin bone the knee bone the end of
my femur and then folded the calf muscle
into where the
hamstring used to be so it doesn't do
anything but it filled that wound enough
that i can put on a socket on that limb
you know you really thank god for them
seriously
thank god since we met there you've gone
through like that's
so much more advanced it's it's pretty
the same actually
is it it looks so different dude yeah
how mobile
is that pretty mobile yeah for walking
yeah yes
do you have a different one for running
i got a blade yeah um it's good but
it's not like running like it hurts the
hard rimmer on the top rubs my skin off
around my groin
you don't want skin off around your
groin it sucks um so this look i lift it
up i can't do anything with it it just
it doesn't do anything like to make it
work i have to walk i have to swing i
have to use the motion and gravity and
all that
but it's better than did you ever do any
chopping sucks
my leg is so strong i just posted a
video the other day um
i was up in vegas training and i did a
box jump and i hadn't done it i saw that
dude yeah and i was like
i was thinking what was the height for
that i don't know i don't know what the
height was i think they're written on
the boxes i haven't actually looked at
it i saw it he did a one-legged box
thoroughly impressed with myself you
should have been bro i don't even know
who was the uh and might be a weird
question did you ever do any work with
that he was that australian
uh dude who he won uh obviously murdered
his wife or girlfriend but he was the
only one
oh he's south africa i'm sorry yeah
he was a stud man yeah yeah they called
him the blade runner he was
knee amputations so it's very different
to having an above knee
if you've got your knee you're good to
go all you got to do is replicate a foot
it's when you have just easier yeah
because it's just a spring
yeah blade easier as far as pain
watch this look at this dude oh look at
um tell me
let's be 37 watch this one get though
that's the one i failed and fell over
that's
come on this is in uh
vegas yeah you think you could do you i
don't think i could do two legs
there's no way yeah my friend i was
training with is actually really fit and
sporty and he wouldn't even give it a go
yeah that is
pretty impressive dude ah
that's cool first of all i got no hops
my son
jacob is tall he's got hops i don't he's
half jewish half asian so i don't know
where the hops from
yeah dude it's like two negatives made a
positive i don't know how it works he's
two short people mom's asian asian bro i
know i didn't know that so ready for
this
he dunked on me in my driveway and
when he dumped on me dude his dick was
in my face
and he was hanging there for a second
and he goes yeah i go hey just so you
know you're never doing that again
he goes no i'll be able to dunk for a
long time i go no i'll throw you down
before you're dicks in my face again
you'll be able to dunk but you're not
dick facing me ever again
but he's got ups have you i wonder how
close to a rim you could come in oh not
even close
dude that's got to be 30 something
inches yeah it looks like a 30 inch vert
but
it's it's different like i can i guess i
can get my leg up higher as well like
vertical i really couldn't do it
differently i could
just touch the rim when i had two legs
well i could barely it's impressive
either way yeah it's not terrible you
got some current events chin
yes it gets warm in here
i don't know the ac is messed up right
now is it messed up
we're trying to work on it oh wait quick
question paul yeah since you're here i
just want to ask you do you ever get
like the phantom sensations that people
talk about
never goes away oh really never not for
a second every single day
i mean my foot that's not there in my
hand that's not there have like this
sense of um
intense pins and needles and cramping
it's but it's kind of like white noise
like
it just falls into the background and
tune it out until someone
brings it up oh [ __ ] sorry about that
now everyone knows not to break until uh
man i was doing all right
and now it's even hotter in here
sorry about that uh absolute favorite
thing to do by the way is to see you
slowly crush somebody's hand with your
oh it's it's it's really because
somebody who may be a little bit of an
[ __ ]
just a little too mouthy yeah you can
squeeze hard
in the right spot and it's not like it's
really strong it's just that there's
no relief there's no yeah no like so if
you get him in the wrong angle crushing
the thing the hand doesn't let go
it will just keep crushing up yeah
i'm not gonna lie to you that would be
kind of fun to do
yeah i can't hold a starbucks cup though
without smushing it no i can't hold
anything
plastic it'll just crush it yeah it's
like i gotta put my
starbucks down and get my key out listen
if you jerked off with your right hand
not anymore
i mean that is how you pull the skin off
the sausage
no one wants a skinless sausage yeah man
you really you had to
learn lefty yeah yeah that was hard
really like
too i've said i keep catching myself
saying like you gotta stop saying like
yeah it's tough yeah
um so it must have been difficult bro
i bet you i would it would be harder for
me to brush my teeth lefty than to jerk
off lefty
you'd be amazed at what you can do when
you don't have a choice yeah yeah i'm
sure like trying to get your shoelaces
with one hand
and your left hand or using a dustpan
and broom
i'm going to try that right stuff all
right i've got an electric toothbrush so
i don't have to worry about you
yeah with one hand well kinda i cheat i
use the
yeah i use the crook in my forearm as
well or my robot hand
there's no way i'm doing snakes but yeah
having to learn to do things
not just one-handed but with my
non-master hand yeah um
i learned patience and perseverance yeah
you have just
any other questions chin you have one
more just one last one
yeah because you know we shook hands
outside right and it was like perfect
amount of pressure how do you control
that
that thing well i gave you the girl
shake yeah i didn't i didn't
just squeeze a little bit then let go
but if i switch it to be drinking grip
which is that you know that's cool but
how did how do you operate it though
i give it a little click in the forearm
the catamaran
so that's my open is here my clothes is
there holy [ __ ] if i want to change the
grip from beer drinking to normal
i give it a little boop it beeps and
that goes into neutral so i shook your
hand with that
if i'd shaken it like that it would have
crushed it yeah it's a little bit and
how long have you had
that device probably six years so it
hasn't technology gotten better so i'm
sure
it hasn't gotten better no what are we
doing uh
so many hundreds of millions of dollars
went into the research
while the war was very active and people
were coming home in the in the droves
missing limbs and so the government
poured heaps of money into it
and because now you know the war's still
going on there's still people dying
americans and australians out there
dying but it's not as prevalent now and
so the money from the government has
dried up and so the research has dried
up yeah and so
it went for they have this huge leap and
it's true through all wars
technology is advanced massively through
every war
and so it's it's developing
incrementally now
as instead of huge leaps and bounds so
this leg is the newest one you can get
but it hasn't got that much more than
what i had from the last two
so it's waterproof now and it has a
running mode but i don't have the
bouncy have you seen the story i don't
know what made me think this just
because they were talking about
uh they were gonna have to amputate his
like have you heard the story about alex
smith yeah
quarterback for the redskins yes you
know and during the game he got tackled
he had a compound fracture
and you know he was a guy and i blew my
leg out not a big deal i'll come back
from it
but bacteria got in there and so two
days into
his hospital stay his entire leg blew up
horribly did you see the picture oh yeah
that was one of the most
infectious so his wife was like we don't
want him to die
yeah i know he loves football but if he
gets worse amputate the legs so
and they have the doctor on then they're
crying the wife and the doctor are
crying because they're trying to decide
do we imitate his leg can never play
again
he didn't want to do it now through
rehab he they've redid he had
all these stinson's leg and screws and
all this [ __ ] and now this [ __ ]
guy
is going to be on the roster for the
redskins that's amazing it's
you watch the i think they did it was
like 60 it's
nuts yeah the the the the picture with i
i i with um with the stints in it but
the picture with
the day difference with how much the
infection had grown out tonight
my leg blew up like this yeah it goes
out of it i wonder how they got that
bacteria under control and
they it's a fascinating the the east
yeah there's his legs
they were saying and his body wasn't
taken that's like that thing that the
asian people use to make them taller
yeah yeah yeah
does that really work yeah yeah
apparently apparently it's torturous
and how long ago was this compared to
him being on the roster this was
two years ago right years ago yeah so
they show the pictures of his
the bacteria eating away his muscle it
is secret it was his flesh they showed
on espionage
and you know what that is the true power
of the human body and the human mind
that
humans can overcome stuff like that we
really are
more powerful than what we think it's
not but they show him like going through
the therapy and they're like man i'm
telling you man the chance of playing
aren't good
and he just keeps hitting it every day
the reason i watch
shows like alone i don't know if you
watch alone and you and i have talked
about it can't do that show either but
the reason i watched
shows like alone is because sometimes i
need to be reminded
that the human body can take
as much as the brain your brain will
allow it to it's like
david goggins i think he says that once
you think you're at your limit you're
still only at 40 percent
it's so it just that show for me i was
like i sometimes i just need to be
reminded like
i can always push more i cannot in that
show alone
they drop these people off dude in the
arctic and you get to survive 100 days
but no camera people you have to carry
your own camera
60 pack around by yourself this dude
killed
an uh a like a giant oxen
with a knife by himself
he ran by and knifed it and then it
would go oh and then he went by again
and
knife it [ __ ] crazy
he had shot it once in the ass with an
arrow and then did a couple of
shanks but i but but it just reminds me
these people are by themselves
they're [ __ ] eating grass and digging
up root they're
wolves it's another thing that you know
we were talking about earlier that i
just don't need to do you don't need to
do it yeah i don't need i have no desire
to i've done survival in the ocean it
sucks
but yeah and these you get 44 hours
that's why is that something
they compensate you for that yeah no i
can't get over it dude
right if i'm your age i'm like you want
to do what yeah yeah
we'll do it we're at the time
there's only one paul here yeah and this
is the price it's
a great choice i want your scientists to
do it let me know how fun that's gonna
be
half the scientists don't even get in
the water that's what i'm saying like
find someone else to do it oh we can't
all right cool here's the page yeah
brandon's like this and it's uh my whole
this whole time like
they should pay them more man yeah man i
never think that i'm gonna die so
as far as i'm concerned life is just a
series of stories and i
i want to feel when i go to my death bed
next time exactly the same way i feel
the first time like i have
no regrets i'm with you i just want
money in your bank yeah
yeah yeah i love that i'm with you well
you're not gonna die we'll put all that
in your eulogy it's beautiful 44 hours
yeah
we're actually in contract negotiations
now i'm gonna i'm gonna add that we
might call you winners uh call me man
be my manager i'm like again again yeah
yeah let me let me give you a list of
people who will don't go find something
to do it paul's one of four
you're gonna be my little johnny
negotiation dude let me do it for you
man
who else is gonna do it and then do it
well and then be able to articulate it
and talk about it
also missing two limbs
making 200 over 200 million dollars a
year who's that
the guy that runs discovery channel yeah
wow he can pony up more than
whatever 44 hours yeah are you out of
your [ __ ] what's your price what's
your
i'm just just what's your price tag 44 i
want to know
if they go b life's too good for me to
do that no no no no no no
give me a price act like a baby here's
what we're going to do 44 hours in the
ocean
surrounded by sharks surrounded by
sharks no food no water all the sharks
we're going to give we can swim how many
people are you with just one other what
other people am i with
am i with paul you can be with your
brother
he sucks with sharks too you get one you
get one trying to get
a pick paul i get paul okay you give me
paul oh you get paul what's it taken for
you to be we don't know each other that
well so i'm sure we'd start bickering at
each other too oh yeah
our twentieth make a good show man
you're gonna get really pissed off yeah
by the way and i'm picturing youtube big
[ __ ] cuddling up on that raft
right there like
dude yeah you get close
well honestly
i don't think how about no filming
nothing you're just doing it for the
experience
but they're still going to pay you you
don't get any social media no tv
okay i'm going to tell you the truth not
filmed less money
what not because that way i can get rid
of the bravado and i could just be like
okay this is me for 44 hours
oh dude 10 hours in the bottle's out the
window but how am i true not when the
camera's there
you get so tired yeah it was out the
window
nightfall oh that's the part c and i
don't want pitch dark
yeah height hours how many pit like how
many straight up
[ __ ] sounds like am i am i going to
make when a shark hits the boat all of
them
yeah paul i'm like paul tell me another
story
how dark was it like pitch black that's
dark so you put your head underwater
you can't see a single thing and then
you turn your torch on and there's a
shark going past your feet
chin how much would you do yeah i
wouldn't do it oh i would you know
there's no price
44 hours i would think i would die and i
don't think it's worth it no no paul's
with you you're not to die paul's going
to coach you through it you might not
die
okay i might not die because you're not
going to die of hunger in 44 hours
you're not getting the only thing you
die of is that shark
well you can die of dehydration in that
time depending on the heat 44 hours
yeah i thought you had three days well
the heat you're in the water you're in
the water one the saltwater dehydrates
you quicker
and plus you're moving constantly
because you've got to stay afloat you're
gonna have to pee in my mouth paul
i find it interesting that you wouldn't
decide to drink your own
no we don't have to you can just suck it
out of my wetsuit
yeah i had a full body pee rash no
no no price gin i thought you were gonna
say i won't pee in your mouth but you
can suck it out
well i had to i had to [ __ ] i had to
take a shot on the second one i had to
the first show didn't [ __ ] for 44 hours
my body just went into survival mode
yeah
second shoot had to [ __ ] middle of the
night i got a little knife and i got to
cut a hole out of my ass
bouncing around in the ocean like this
you don't understand how hard it is not
to cut anything else off while you're
doing that no
yeah oh and then sharks eat [ __ ] why
don't you just
[ __ ] in your suit no no no and then you
could have that's happening
then i have to do the rest of the show
with my baby you want to get eaten by
the shark no but i'm just saying you
shouldn't seriously [ __ ]
doesn't
dude i don't i don't know you do it for
attention i would say 10 million
10 million because i'm saying that's why
they wouldn't give it to me yeah you did
i was going to say yeah i'm which i was
i was around the
yeah i did 50 000.
dude discovery's working double
50 000 i would do it for 50 000. and
honestly i'm saying 50 000 because i'm
not trained so i feel like there's more
risk and i don't know what i'm doing so
i'm putting a little extra on there but
i'm doing 50 000 because
honestly i'm doing it for the experience
i think they might pay that actually
i'm discovering i think shout out to
shaq i know mike tyson for the five days
i think he got something like half a
million
yeah so you get paid in direct like
level level of your style so definitely
take a zero off that for me
yeah discovery's watching you say
i bet you could push a few more hours on
it too yeah well you're going to get a
lot of screams some jazz hands and some
[ __ ] noises out of me so
that's way more entertaining than me
doing it like you should definitely
discover you definitely i'm terrible i
shut down when i get tired i get cranky
i shut down
me too [ __ ] the cameras i don't know
yeah i don't want to talk to him i just
want to get through this and not die
well like i was a big uh naked afraid
fan super fan like i'd watch what i
talked about on the show
and then they reached out like what are
you thinking naked and afraid i'm like
oh man that'd be fun me and brian could
do i'm like what's it pay like
nothing it's for the experience like
absolutely not yeah no way
i got asked as well yeah no way i got
asked to do dancing with the stars nope
i'm not interested in that is dance with
the stars play though yes
mike catherine would get it weekly i
heard the fame off that's nuts
are you not curious at all oh it's dance
of strangers
bindi uh erwin steven did it in america
nailed it one became like world
sweetheart for yeah i was just gonna do
australia would you just
worth it i know you wouldn't because no
money but would you be more interested
in doing something like alone or naked
and afraid
without the cameras or with the cameras
i like the fact that everything i do on
an adventure
has a little film crew and i get a
little bit you know well it's
it's a professionally made home movie
that you can relive and go look do you
have kids
no no i got a dog do you want kids
eventually yeah how old are you i'm
getting old i'm getting on there it's
about time like 42
you know 43. and your girls held uh 28
yeah sometime yeah yeah but she's it
would be cool for your kids to watch
this stuff and then i i wonder if you
have kids if you tone down the danger
why is your girlfriend if i turn down
the danger if i have kids that's what
i'm saying yeah
yeah because i know i do like there's
certain things i just absolutely i drive
safer
why is your girlfriend only a year older
than my oldest son because he's awesome
because he got i think older women are
too smart to date someone like me
you were like 28 i'm like why does that
sound familiar oh that's my oldest son's
edge
right that's why because i'm a child of
heart yeah
that is why we get along is she into
outdoor activity in swimming
yeah yeah well she we've only been
dating since the start of covert
and so so we've spent a lot of
time together and intense yeah but you
know i think if you can get through that
how do you do that like because that
means early
young relationships so if you just moved
in with somebody during covet
you may not have pooped in front of
somebody oh yeah before the
it puts in the hyperdrive you're oh
we didn't move in together we only just
started dating and so we spent a lot of
time in close proximity hanging out
because we had last coming
sorry with math no no so we had a month
no he was he was straight away
we had like one proper date when we went
out and did that three-day adventure
together and then everything shut down
and so
basically just hanging out at my
apartment walking the dog
uh whatever we could do we went up to um
mount mount mount something
it's like an hour and 10 minutes no hour
and 10 minutes away and there was still
snow there
and so went out there and flew the drone
had a little picnic and you know we did
a lot of picnics
i actually had to wrestle with a dude
with a gun not long ago what yeah
so we we were having for a discovery
again
they didn't pay me
me and my girl were having a picnic down
at the lagoon at um playa del rey
yeah and so we're just in there we'd had
two bottles of maui it was kind of like
a special date day
uh smashed two bottles of moe and all of
a sudden the the homeless guys from the
toilet block
came running over there's like four of
them they're like get behind the rock
this guy with the gun
so i put everyone behind the rock and
obviously i head towards the road where
the guy with the gun is for some strange
reason
there there's couple did you have a gun
i had nothing no nothing and so there's
a guy on the phone calling the police
and there's a couple talking about and
they're pointing down the roads like
what's going on so there's this guy down
the end of the street in a white prius
he's been he was waving a gun around
he's got out of the car and i'm watching
him and then he gets back in the car and
so i asked them
where does this road go because there's
one way and they say it goes up around
the block and comes out the other side
on the other side of these buildings
so i say how can we get up there and
they say yeah you just cut through these
buildings here so i'm like you on the
phone you come with me you guys you stay
here
cut through the building there's people
on the streets having balcony uh having
balcony parties
and so i yell at him and i say hey guys
there's a there's a dude with a gun
coming down the street everyone should
go inside so they all stay on their
balconies
yeah as you can see everyone listen
no not now no one they it's so
i get to like dude this guy with one
arm's left gets shot get out of here
and say that's exactly yeah yeah quick
get your phones out
exactly that's the guy from discovery
we're gonna see a shooter give me a shot
man this is great
so the the guy on the phone and say stay
behind the cars and he's the dude in the
car has come up around the corner his
white prius he's just sitting at the end
of the street doing nothing
so i'm watching him through the window
waiting to see if he moves and he starts
coming down the street so i time it so
i'm not in front of the car but i'm in
an awkward enough position that he has
to stop if he doesn't want to hit me
and he stops and i start going overtly
friendly yelling like i'm at a party i'm
a little drunk like hey what's going on
man
and i walk around the back of the car
checking the windows to make sure no one
else is in there there's no other guns
and i come up on his window
and i just be frowned what's going on
what are you doing i glanced down and
he's sitting
in his seat with his hand on a pistol
like that and so
i asked him a question he starts to
answer i jab down for the gun and i grab
his hand
and his gun in the same grip and he
panics he yells he hits the accelerator
and my arm gets hit by the edge of the
window and pulls it off the gun
and he just bolts and that's the end of
the story
let me ask you why is that your instinct
australian captain america i know
i'm like he's down there okay i'm gonna
head this way here's what's here's
what's funny by the way when you're
walking down the street
when i first met you you had the
three-piece suit and you had the you
looked like a bond villain
because he he had the perfect night when
he's walking down the street looking
like captain america you know people are
like
day saved i love that he's like
you get inside you over here and
everyone's like
a good friend of mine he keeps telling
me he's going to put me in his movies as
a bad guy so i'm just waiting for i love
him
i think give me a flamethrower or
something
wolverine you call the cops and then
they picked up the guy on the phone
called the cops and they pulled i went
back down again
like what you're hoping just to take the
gun and then what yeah and just
if i can detain him for the police then
do that if not at least drive him away
because he's
this is a family neighborhood it's quiet
yeah it's beautiful and so you can't
just go driving around a neighborhood
flashing a gun that's [ __ ] not on
your watch
not after i've had two yeah what'd you
say yeah
god i wish you lived in my neighborhood
if there was any problems i'm like i'm
calling paul
yeah i'm going to call paul he'll come
over and my friends think i'm
stupid yeah so i just went back down and
continued the
and was that and that was when you your
first date with your girl she's probably
like
what the [ __ ] was she like did paul just
leave me with these four homeless guys
yeah yeah yeah
yeah he just ran here hey fellas watch
it
yeah yeah eat as much of the food you
need to yeah yeah
i'm glad to know the story two bottles
in you're like
let's go [ __ ] this guy with a gun up
yeah that's probably more so than if i
didn't have it yeah
i was booted it was like months into
corona i was so
bored i needed some excitement some
action yeah it'd be how terror had been
if you went to go and just like
shot you in the in your arms and your
girl's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing dude i really didn't think
about that at all pretty gangster dude
too bad you're not a cop yeah you could
use people like you yeah
it's it's pretty amazing man that is the
exact opposite of what my instinct
you need cops like that yes we need more
cops like that but
which i think uh the majority of them
are well there's a lot of good cops
there are a lot
of i would say 99.9 of cops are good
yeah there's this
hit out on him it doesn't make sense
it's
you know what it started yeah it's look
man the the unfortunate truth about
bringing cops trained like cam
yeah yeah you do well under high
pressure who was talking about that
um was it uh jocko or someone was
talking about
how poorly trained the police we talked
about this last time yeah yeah yeah and
so they gave me are you talking to rogan
is that where you're listening to
something like that he's talking about
because i'm not defunding he's like yeah
you need it no you didn't
only train for like 20 hours dude to
become an infantry soldier we've got
you know you go through boot camp for 10
weeks then you go through uh
infantry training for eight weeks or no
like 12 weeks and then you continuously
train
all the time and so the cops are getting
what a couple of a month or something
training
20 hours and they put in this high
pressure situation like god he freaked
out yeah
dealing with the worst of humanity what
do you think's going to happen
they need to take they need to be given
time off they need better rotations they
need better training
they need like not to be sent out to all
these
crappy stupid um like domestic fights
you know keep them in reserve and give
them time for training so they can
respond to
the things where they're actually
required because most cops i know would
do the exact same like
most capstone are badass but they're
walking towards the problem not away
from me there's such stunts so when i
see everyone hating on cosplaying like
you you you don't know this
the police how what is it six months
with your just
taking your driver's license you have to
have a permit for six months which means
they're making you train
to drive a car six months i i don't know
if you have to be in the academy for six
months to become an officer i don't know
what it's like but it's through training
it's kind of crazy like we're just not
giving them the tools
no they have the toughest especially now
the tough stuff and then also if you're
18 and you're looking for a job and you
look at social media you look at
news right now do you really want to be
a cop i saw one lady cop drive by the
other day i felt bad i'm like [ __ ] man
that would suck
yeah people just think bonehead some of
the standards as well i i can't remember
if it's as bad here but it's pretty poor
in australia
as a whole that there's a lot of police
you look at them and go
you're not doing anything you couldn't
chase me
you're out of shape yeah dude good luck
with that bubba
yeah yeah it takes away from these
people that really really dedicated
themselves to
i know some badass galapagos dude if he
gets called to your thing you're [ __ ]
yeah you've got military guys as well
you know it's probably some of the best
ones because they're so highly trained
with
the the high stress situations over and
over again trauma training all that sort
of stuff and so
these guys need to be the leader setting
the example and maybe taking aside
the the guys on your squad and giving
them that extra bit of training the idea
of
de-escalation needs to just be
reinforced
reinforced because all it takes to turn
a
semi-confrontational situation into a
real confrontational situation
is two dudes who aren't gonna back down
nobody's willing to de-escalate
yeah psychologically yeah yeah yeah then
they're going to fund all that sort of
training for everyone and that's
weeks and months but you know you know
what they're doing now defunding all
that
yeah so then it's that's ridiculous yeah
dude um
what do you got jim all right first of
all [ __ ] story dude i know yeah
awesome
okay so a fisherman from florida
recently got bitten by a lemon shark
and this is making news cause a couple
years ago he was also
reported to have had been attacked by an
alligator while he was alligator hunting
paul lemon shark
not bad right uh yeah it'll still mess
you up really
like also not bad unless there's food in
the water he probably i'm guessing he
had some food with him he was
fishing or something but they're
generally pretty calm they're very
docile unless there's food in the water
and they're the sharks i had to push
away
when they threw the fish blood into the
water and so they can get now is that a
lemon there
no it looks like it i can't tell i'm
thinking oh i'm thinking of a leopard
no that's a um what they call either a
sand tiger or a ragged tooth shark
uh we call it um uh no shark in
australia they're
they're very docile very very yeah
because i've been in the water with them
and pushed them away
and um and i wasn't and i can't tell the
picture
oh look i put there i put the fish in
the hole right before i surfaced wham
yeah so he's he had fish in the water
yeah yeah see that's the thing
you're making yourself part of the food
chain at that point you've got the food
they want attached to your body
you gotta you can't get upset when you
get
i mean i feel like he survived an
alligator attack yes that's way worse
right
how big was the alligator another good
point but the alligator will
death throw you right or is that the
croc i think both of them do it
did you see the alligator they saw in
queensland that monster alligator
catching crocodiles for discovery
channel those things
are way more terrifying than sharks
these things are freaking dinosaurs
like 18 20 foot long bring up that one
hunt
aren't they perfect like like they have
they haven't really changed that
much 200 million years did you see that
did you see
the other thing they just discovered
last week scientists discovered
uh the the back in the day they were
alligators size of buses and they said
their teeth were the size of bananas and
they would attack
t-rex it's nuts i mean where's that one
in queensland
scientists are trying to bring these
creatures i know like jurassic park
yeah but please do not do that but you
so you you
you think the the alligator and
crocodile as far as hunters
you think they're because the sharks
seem for me to be the perfect hunter
in that environment so they're perfectly
evolved for the specific environment
yeah show paul that one
the one he's a monster yeah they this is
like two days ago
look how big this [ __ ] salty is
it's hard to tell when you've got no
context i know that's the only problem
it looks pretty big if you there's a guy
on social media called matt wright an
australian guy
and he has crocodiles in australian
saltwater crocodiles
in his like i don't know what it is a
sanctuary or whatever
but he feeds them and he'll slap the
water and these
enormous crocodiles come charging
himself how
what what would you call a big what's a
big size for a croc
for a saltwater croc is that it i
wouldn't want to mess with anything
at all for starters but a big really big
is probably
16 to 20 foot good god so we were
catching them up in darwin like 18 hours
south of darwin in
legit dinosaur country and we jump out
of the boats in the middle of the night
into like waste deep water and go ashore
and you just
is you shine your light around to try
and catch eye glint but if they're under
the surface you can't do it so you jump
out and you get to shore as quick as
possible
then we catch these crocs strap cameras
to them to get croc cam
it was pretty interesting but also kind
of terrifying what was the was that for
a show for discovery yeah that was
shark's first crocs
so when you jump in the water like that
there's no guarantee that there isn't a
crock right when you jump
guarantee whatsoever and are they jesus
going to attack
if they're not hungry trucks will so
fast crocs are going to attack even if
they're not absolutely
they're aggressive what about alligator
i'm not real familiar with alligators i
think they would
um because they're just predators that's
just what they do
they're dinosaurs yeah look at that
they're way more terrifying than sharks
oh dude
so scared yeah this guy's wild he's got
a i think he's got his own show
uh or he did but uh very interesting to
talk about he's your friend no i i've
never met him he's just a crocodile yeah
and they these things are deceptively
fast on land
they can but only over very short
distances because they're so heavy
do you hear about that the like two or
four year old that died at disney world
oh yeah you got sucked into the pond by
a gator or something yeah
what yeah because there's like you know
around disney world there's like they
have like their coves or whatever yeah
and people thought because disney world
that they're safe to go into those
lakes or whatever and this four-year-old
went into the lake and then a crocodile
i was like oh [ __ ] look at this
yeah the father went in after it that's
really heartbreaking
the boy's very cute too so when was that
it was like two years ago
ah dude it's hard to watch when you see
his face
anyway let's get back to it
disney world huh i'll pass
so what are you what have you guys been
doing since everything's been shut down
do you do
virtual comedy shows i didn't have one
yet i did one i went on the road oh how
was
cleveland cleveland was outstanding dude
shows were good
shows were made were shut down now
really
i said i listen it wasn't me
but i will tell you man they were so
they have an hvac system that doesn't do
recycled air
so he pumps it in from the outside and
pumps it straight out
he everybody was wearing mask gloves
servers the plastic partitions nick is
amazing the best
he did a great job i got to tell you the
reason i like going to cleveland is
because every time i go something weird
happens
two times ago when we went jacob my son
saw somebody get shot in the alley
it was hilarious okay i know it sounds
yeah it doesn't sound
okay we're walking back from the show
and you know that hotel is right near
the yes
the old that that haunted yeah yeah but
so
and my son and i have a very we great
relationship
but the one thing we don't do is smoke
weed together i just won't do it
he's he's old enough to smoke so he can
do it if he wants to still but i'm not
going to do it with him yeah
right so i know he knows i smoke weed
because he's alive and he steals your
stash yeah and i know he's supposed to
be we're walking back from the um
show and we're in the alley and the
night before we had ordered a quesadilla
from the hotel but it had come with
caesar salad dressing as
and i'm like that is whacked you don't
put caesar salad dressing with a [ __ ]
quesadilla unless you're high yeah well
after that i even tried it and you added
chocolate
but i told him i don't want that whack
quesadilla i said come back down and get
some
food from this place that bowling alley
serves food right across right
he goes okay so i'm up in the room and
my room looked right over where the
place was
and i hear these five pop pop and i was
like
oh no and i walk over the window and i'm
like that was right where jacob is
and i pulled back the blinds and there
was a body in the alley
and i called jacob and i'm like dude and
he goes hey i just saw somebody get shot
i go i know man i go get up here and he
goes
well i'm waiting for the food right
and i go no i go no dude look at the
food i don't [ __ ] the phone get the case
to deal with
yeah we'll get some more food and he's
another long pause and he goes
well they're not going to come back
again right i mean now i'm safe right
they're not shooting her twice
i love his mind and i told him i go
you're right wait for the food yeah yeah
because they said they let him take
everybody's food was it a gang related
or was going on the guy who they were
trying to shoot died at the other end of
the alley he ran away adrenaline
the woman who got shot in the leg by the
way who was there
was a woman who an hour earlier
had stopped and talked to jacob and i
and asked us for directions
so i'm sitting high in my room i'm just
a tourist and i'm freaking out that
jacob was almost shot
and he was right there and i'm already
freaking out with that guilt and jacob
turns to me he goes dad you ever think
about
like if that woman hadn't stopped to
talk to us she'd have never gotten shot
i'm like
man why are you [ __ ] with me like
yeah yeah yeah and i was that's hot
yeah i got to tell you i was so freaked
out that night and he was a grown-up he
was pro
i i told him i go hey man we're not
going to sleep like this but
you're just going to come laying next to
me he's on another level of high walk
than you are yeah yeah
yeah you look at you look at discarded
couches people are getting shocked
but last time i was in cleveland the
weird thing that happened is this dude
was
finger banging his girlfriend in the
front row full on
that's aggressive but here's the thing
too it wasn't like a secret under the
table diddle
the best way i can explain it and this
is is he looked like a dj scratching a
record he was this far away
and he was making eye contact with me
and i was like this that's some prison
[ __ ] like this
is aggressive how do you call him out
during the show
here's the thing so the server asked me
why didn't you tell us i'm like
honestly i didn't want to kick him out
because it gave me something different
to look at
yeah you know what i mean i'm so used to
seeing all you [ __ ] yeah
i ended up kicking him out because he
ended up talking at his table and i told
him when he was leaving i go dude i got
no problem with you finger banging your
girlfriend
but if you talk you're disrespectful
that's when we gotta get you yeah yeah
yeah that's when i draw the line but
cleveland
cleveland i love it what an adventure
city i'm gone
have you never been to cleveland i think
great
i ended up meeting one of the baseball
players cleveland brown
is that the football team no i think it
was somewhere else um
but i think i was supposed to go there
for a speaking job this year and it just
got canned yeah cleveland's great that
rock and roll hall of fame is great
the fr flymen slimons slimens
i heard you eat there not this time but
that's slime and corned beef the best
they have a breakfast yeah go ahead yeah
chris is his friend who's the marine oh
word you're the big dude he told me
uh he was like i want to try stand up
i'm like listen man
you did i go i said just so you know the
first thing that better comes out of
your mouth better be about how
[ __ ] massive you got to dress it
right away you better be talking about
everyone insanely large you are because
everybody else is going to be like
yeah if we don't laugh it's not going to
murder he's the bouncer introduced
he's i'm telling you the first guy where
i'm like why is his wrist
more muscular than myself dude you
haven't met our other friend boomer so
me and chris and boomer are like
three best mates out here and chris is
from louisiana lives in georgia boomer
bill craig
ex-navy special forces medic he's bigger
than chris
jesus christ yeah big beardy lives in
birmingham alabama shirt shout out to
chris and boomer
let me give you that oh yeah shout out
to chris and boomer
what a great name yeah dude i mean if
when he he still comes out every now and
then does he say yeah
yeah he's he's in san diego next week i
think [ __ ]
love this dude but and he's got some
great stories
oh great stories dude he had his first
he's like he had his first kid at 15.
um you know and he we're talking about
louisiana
um and he basically quit school went to
work
uh couldn't make enough money so i
joined the navy to supply for his kid
and that he raised
five children and only one of them is
his biological son
that's how good a man this guy is also
just like a nice
when you see him you're like no but one
of the nicest guys
i think when you're that big you'll be
pretty why not yeah
yeah you know what i mean he should be
yeah absolutely he's good at that
de-escalation sort of thing
yeah that's really good he's dealt with
his whole life yeah but also like
when he walks up you know what you don't
want to do escalate no hell no you're
like that
they grab you with one of those huge ham
hocks and just lift you off the ground
hand yeah is like i remember the first
time i shook his hand i'm like
he could punch a hole in my chest and
[ __ ] i love going out with those guys
you never have to worry about
anything everyone's so friendly we've
got the gigantor and the robot guy like
yeah we don't have any problems did you
have any others chin you want anyway are
you good
uh we're two hours right now i think
yeah we always go long huh sorry buddy
don't say sorry he's great but amazing
paul uh i can't believe you came with no
coffee dude
everybody knows i'm a coffee i i would
have a coffee iv if i could
spill striker coffee i know i wish i
knew that they were a coffee fiend i got
my own
coffee company in australia veteran
owned yeah yeah it's called strike a
coffee company how am i what
are you really a veteran if you don't
have a coffee company
black rifle ironside or
um and it's all really good coffee yeah
it's great ours is amazing
um we get it it's family owned technical
old italian guy built the coffee roaster
by hand
and it's done with this technique passed
down through generations from italy to
it and that
like we it's all made in australia and i
was trying to get it out here it's like
we can't because
the family does this specifically and
they know all the roasts that work with
it
so we do small batch funnily enough one
of our biggest customers is canada
um so we're shipping everywhere but it's
just kind of small time at the moment my
buddy ian's running it he's
you would love him man he's a how long
english you ex-gangster from
england um big scary thai boxer like as
big as chris
tattoos all over him but once again one
of the nicest dudes
thai boxer is that the same as muay thai
yeah we're talking about yes yeah
and what the name striker company
i don't know how they came up with it i
was kind of like on the
at the skirts of it yeah i just support
and you know and
but uh these guys put so much work into
looking for the perfect roast the
perfect beans
all of that and so we got uh four blends
now
it's um danger close which is the shirt
that i'm wearing
which is i think a medium roast but the
one that everyone seems to love
is door kicker because it's it's this
super strong blend and it's like kind of
a pre-workout so if you don't want to
take the chemicals of
pre-workouts and all that stuff it's a
double triple dose of caffeine
we had um we had this guy called
commando steve who used to
be the one of the main guys for uh the
the biggest loser he's like the hardcore
ex-commando dude that used to train him
so we gave some to him and his friend
before a workout they got about 10
minutes in
and looked at each other and then looked
at ian we're like what the
[ __ ] is in this [ __ ] really yeah they
love this max
caffeine check check check you just met
one of my friends from the biggest
yeah do you know jen wiederstrom she was
one of the trainers on there
but it's so funny i had just i had been
telling each of you individually about
each other and then you sent me a
picture i was hanging out with
another legendary human being by the
name of rudy reyes
yeah this guy this guy is such an
incredible dude
he was in generation kill and they were
basing you remember that show the series
about the uh
infantry soldiers in iraq oh yes really
great show
was it like a real like a it was a
fictional story but it was as close to
real as they could get it
and they had a lot of veterans in it and
rudy they had a character based on him
but towards the end
it's like no one can play rudy like rudy
so he ended up being in it and he's just
this
ball of energy and passion and his
everything is about love and
striving for greatness he's just he's
like no other person i've ever met
incredible guy that's amazing she is she
is a badass dude yeah she's jacked she
is
she's like a hammer thrower yeah she is
and she was on uh
olympic palace uh what was it called uh
american gladiator she's one of the
gladiators
jesus early on such a sweetheart yeah
but but a
just a complete badass in the gym
yeah complete complete looks like it
well paul we love you man dude he's
coming back straight up
to see you guys again shark week
discovery channel they gotta pay you
more
yeah yeah i'll work towards it i'll call
you next week little john
yeah i'm up for a little brendan
discovery i'm up for 50 g if you want to
throw me in the middle 72 hours yeah
we're up to 72. yeah dude you're gonna
have to find someone else
yeah you know 72 with great whites i'm
on board
hit me up but uh we'll find something
better than that it's already been done
we'll push the boundaries elsewhere you
got to come with me though man yeah i'll
do it
you know i'm up for an adventure in
october is when you're going to mexico
october yeah ah that sounds funny it's
dude it's five day trip because it's a
day to get out there a day to get back
three days on the boat hot tubs free
booze
do you think it's a good idea to go
underwater high or a bad idea
it depends on the person for me i don't
smoke terrible idea
yeah for you perfectly yeah i feel like
you thrive while you're high i do i
don't i feel so much better when i'm how
do you stand up high
yeah i don't know rogan does too i can't
yeah i know
i'd get drunk on stage no no dude i
couldn't do it
the only time i've been high in probably
the last
two decades was with ronda rousey and
her husband travis
when we were doing the shoot and we're
in yeah
absolutely yes and so they took some to
fiji
and we're sitting on the back of this
multi-million dollar yacht and they're
hitting and it came around to me i'm
like well i don't really smoke but i'll
give it a go and i sure probably
hit it like a little [ __ ] not even any
smoke came out and i'm like
[ __ ] this i'm gonna i'm gonna hit it
next time and so it came around i went
until my lungs were like full and then i
blew it out went back around
i spent the next 30 minutes proofreading
everything i was going to say
to the point by the time i was ready to
say it the conversation had moved on
yeah and i'm just spouting out
random [ __ ] i love it i ended up in
bed i don't want you high man
yeah don't get high no i love being high
i've i almost feel more comfortable
we were gonna try mushrooms together i'm
listen you know
mushroom sharks i take mushrooms every
monday night you know i'm on board
i don't i don't think that's a good idea
because you get a different sort of
landscape that you see and if you need
to put your hand on a shark in a
specific
spot but you can't really see
spitballing ideas here no
i would i wouldn't recommend any drugs
whatsoever
legal or illegal dealing with wild
animals do not do it it's a bad idea
but let's revisit the mushroom idea i'm
in town all right
i i don't really know much about it but
yeah i do let me know how it goes
are mushrooms legal yeah no at my house
they are
is that cow are they well no they're not
if they're not legal i'm not doing them
here because i'm on a visa
i don't want to mess that up i love
living in america
so we'll go to where they're like
colorado or something i'll tell you what
i will take them for you
dude there's so much there's so much
research going into psychedelics
mushrooms and all that sort of stuff for
ptsd
yeah all that sort of stuff so look i'm
not against any of that stuff i think
uh tobacco and liquor kill far more
people than oh they're like you're good
in california
oh really yeah so from for me the the
especially with the mushrooms the next
day
i feel so much more enlightened is not
the right california
i feel so much more aware
of being alive like i feel
uh the day after mushrooms i feel so
connected
yeah i really do here's here it gets
tricky it says legalized in oakland
california santa cruz
yeah oh sorry criminal cities they
decriminalized them there yeah okay
it's like where i grew up in canberra in
australia was the only state
that marijuana was decriminalized so you
wouldn't get a criminal record for
having a personal stash
um but funnily enough it's the same
state where the politicians sit
so the same state where fireworks and
like um
like what do they call those things like
peak bars where you go into a box and
you
pay money into a hole and there's a
chick checking taking off
oh yeah so yeah that was legal there as
well
nowhere else in the whole of australia
just where the politicians live yeah
that's funny he's not going to do
mushrooms with you it's illegal
all right well i'll do them for both of
us and then i'll let you know
i'll just watch you yeah no that won't
make me feel good
just lead you astray start telling you
crazy stories military
and let me tell you what it felt like to
get bit no
i love it yeah no yeah we love you man
you got open door policy here man
thank you man appreciate it so good to
see you guys
i gotta get some dude i'll send you
something i got you also i gotta say you
love whiskey i just found out
my buddy blake runs the uh los angeles
distillery whiskey connoisseur i
hate whiskey i love their whiskey i'm a
mexican
tequila guy dude yeah but whiskey los
angeles distillery
they've got whiskey they've got um
sailor strength right no he's up
sailor or pirate strength rum like
strong
awesome they've got bourbon yeah i'm
going to get some opera
uh this thursday friday saturday i'm at
salt lake wise guys
the only tickets available are late show
thursday late show saturday
that's t5k.com for tickets that's it man
i'm in
boise at the end of the month um
you can go to my website
comedianjoshwolf.com come watch me
we talk about the mushrooms and the
wheat every monday night
on my facebook fan page i take mushrooms
and smoke weed and turn on my kids
people love it
it's ridiculous it's i draw pictures i
read children's books it's
the it's the weirdest hour you'll spend
i've got a new book coming out this year
i'll read it for you
uncaged i want to give one shout out man
to my friends
puma's been delivering shoes to the
people of cedar sinai uh
that means shoes and um i just want to
say thank you to them publicly for
taking care of the
nurses and the doctors and sending out
stuff they always support and do good
things for people so just i want to give
a giant shout out to them
cool man thank you guys for coming
thanks brother love you guys